at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by humans beat elite the
product is beat elite not meat elite not
beat dat but beat be IET elite which you
might consider an endurance superfood or
what they would call a nitric oxide
activator really all I care about
is this product beat lee was introduced
to me several years ago by a multiple
time world champion and has since been
recommended to me by multiple
world-class athletes and i use it pre
workout for endurance training that
could be a cycling that could be
swimming it is very rarely running but
my subjective experience supports what
some of the research would seem to
indicate and that is that you can
workout say up to 15 to 18 percent
longer if you're looking at
high-intensity interval training hit for
instance and at recovery times so the
let's call it the refractory period for
getting back to peak power output for
instance so I use beat lee just used it
this morning before a 30-minute somewhat
intense swim workout and I have found
that particularly for someone like
myself who has really terrible endurance
genetically speaking my presets are
horrible that it really does allow a 10
to 20 percent boost in shorter workout
performance especially although I do
know people who have used it for 20 mile
runs thirty mile runs much longer
endurance events and they've got all
sorts of different
points about the mechanisms of action
and so on but suffice to say that it is
a lot easier to consume beetle II than
to eat the nitric oxide equivalent of
six whole beets for instance much more
rapidly assimilated and it tastes great
it will also stain your pet polar bear
or your white cotton or your down
pillows so don't spill it on anything
but it does taste delicious I tend to
mix this into a shake that I have
pre-workout in the mornings so there you
have it I've used beetle eat for a
number of years now it is trusted by
hundreds of elite teams athletes and
organizations all over the world and it
is also informed sport certified which
means that it is certified to not
contain any banned substances so if
you're a competitive athlete that is one
fewer thing that you need to worry about
so take your performance to the next
level with beat elite try it out go to
live human calm slash to him to get 20%
off your first purchase the team at
human that's the company is making this
offer exclusive to you my dear listeners
to check it out go to live human dot-com
slash Tim super simple live human calm /
Tim give it a shot
this episode is brought to you by
palette on I love peloton peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right to your
home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into your schedule
making it to the studio or dealing with
some commute to the gym I have a peloton
bike in my master bedroom at home and it
is one of the first things that I do in
the morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take a
shower and I'm in higher gear for the
rest of the day it's beautifully
convenient and has become something that
I actually look forward to and I was
skeptical in the beginning I didn't
think I would dig it and I really do so
you have a lot of options for one if you
like you can ride it live with thousands
of other peloton riders from across the
country on the interactive leaderboard
keep you motivated I tend to use a lot
of the classes on demand and have 4 to 6
of them that I've bookmarked and use
over and over again there are up to 14
new classes every day with thousands of
classes on demand and there are a
variety of workouts to choose from 45
minute classes 20 minute burns hip hop
rock and roll low impact or
high-intensity pick the class structure
and style that works for you peloton has
an amazing roster of incredible
instructors in New York City they really
do have great instructors of every
possible personality and style and you
can find one that you love no matter
what you're in the mood for personally I
use Matt Wilbur's a lot but I use a
bunch of them I'm promiscuous and enjoy
classes from a lot of their instructors
with real time metrics you can track
your performance over time and continue
to beat your personal bests I did not
think the gamification would work for me
and they really hit the nail on the head
it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this cutting
edge indoor cycling bike that brings the
studio experience to your home peloton
is offering listeners of this podcast a
limited time offer go to one peloton
comm that's spelled o-n-e PE l otan comm
enter the code
Tim podcast all one word at checkout and
get $100 off accessories with your
peloton bike purchase get a great
workout at home any time you want to go
to one peloton calm and use the code tim
pug
to get started why hello boys and girls
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
I am here with some my mistake Emma's
bourret sample a MN is like a horse
yeah we say in like as extent if a men
is happy happy you know happy is like if
a horse is a happy but on the internet
and in his clinical duties he's known as
Peter TIA
dr. Peter Tia welcome back to the show
thank you thank you for having me and
Peter for those who do not know anything
about your background will cover just
the basics but what would be a kind of
speaker bio short version of Peter Tia
just to get people up to speed who have
not heard previous episodes part-time
Shepherd part-time racecar driver
part-time Archer part-time doctor and
that pie chart has most of the pie on
dr. what else do we have here
not your interest in jeopardy and I
guess I have to do all the serious stuff
now podcast host courtesy of you podcast
is called the drive and it focuses on
things beyond driving mostly I guess
things related to longevity and and dad
I guess that's another thing on the bio
their responsibility and for those who
have not heard our prior conversations
Peter is my go-to resource for anything
related to extension of lifespan or more
accurately health span so threading the
needle of combining both longevity and
performance and that's across many
different dimensions we're probably not
going to spend all of our time on that
today but Peter is one of the most
methodical
and oftentimes obsessive people I've
ever met and that's coming from me keep
in mind so I think it was an episode one
that we talked about so we're not going
to spend time on it now but Peters very
very very particular etiquette for
stapling which has measurements in the
metric system and so on so we're not
going to get into that but Peter is my
defacto expert when it when it comes to
many different things including
longevity and one of our episodes which
is a group episode of two other very
very accomplished scientists was
actually recorded on Easter Island as a
teaser for people who might want to
explore which is known as Rapa Nui and
is the that the namesake from which
rapamycin is named which we may talk
about and there you have it for preface
to our conversation but we're gonna try
something today which is a first and I
think we're gonna call it temporarily
five things with Peter Tia it might end
up being more than five but I know Peter
pretty well and Peter knows certainly me
quite well I said what do you think of
doing an episode where we talk about say
five things that you're excited about
currently five things you've changed
your mind on in the last whatever it is
a year two years three years whatever
and then five absurd or stupid things
that you do or still do and we're gonna
give that a shot and I think we'll maybe
cycle through do you think we should do
the five excited 5 change 5 stupid in
that grouping or should we do one one
one and kind of cycle through oh that's
a that's a good question
I don't know I I was all mentally
prepared to go from one category to the
next so I would suggest do the opposite
of what I was prepared for perfect let's
cycle through so what is the first the
first thing you'd like to confess or
describe that you're excited about so
the first thing and I guess for the
listener you were very kind enough to
give me a heads up that this is what you
wanted to talk about so I actually did
have some time to think about this which
fortunately allows
to not sound like an idiot which is what
I would have sounded like if you had
just asked me this cold so the first
thing I have on my list about excited
stuff is the centenarian Olympics which
is my favorite sport it's the sport that
I am exclusively training for and it has
become one of the highest priorities
within my medical practice in the past
probably two years so the idea is the
following I had this I think I can call
it an epiphany actually maybe 18 months
ago - two years ago I was at the funeral
of a close friend the parent of a close
friend and you know like all funerals
they're all there's there's a sombre
nature to them but that on some level
people are also generally rejoicing in
the fact that a person hasn't suffered
too much in the case of my friend's
parent who'd been diagnosed with
Alzheimer's disease the time from
diagnosis to death was like six months
and everyone was like oh that's great
you know that this there wasn't much
suffering there but I knew that parent
for many years and what I realized in
spending more time talking with
everybody was that the last 10 years of
their life even though their brain was
still intact
shy of the last six months of that ten
years the body had broken down and the
two things that gave that person the
pleasure you know beyond support
spending time with their grandkids and
things like that which was golf and
gardening like landscape and really some
killer landscaping
we're basically off the table you know
courtesy of Nippon you know like hip
injuries shoulder injuries back injuries
all those other things and so I sort of
reflected on the show and realized that
pretty much the standard path that
people go on which is before they
actually die their physical death you
know the sort of what I call death
certificate death they tend to die some
combination of a cognitive and physical
as an exoskeleton death and so we're
sitting there with a funeral and I'm I
don't know I'm just thinking there's got
to be a way to stop this because
nobody's really thinking about this we
do all this amazing training for
athletes who are you know trying to go
to the Olympics or even being weekend
warriors or doing whatever they're going
to do
but why aren't we training to be
kick-ass 90 year olds so my hypothesis
was well it's just a lack of specificity
I mean the what separates you know a
professional athlete from a weekend
warrior is generally the specificity in
the intensity with which they pursue
this thing so I said well what if we
came up with an event that actually
defined what one would want to be able
to do when there are a hundred using
that just as a benchmark you may never
live to a hundred but to train to
achieve this thing when you're a hundred
you'll obviously be in great shape when
you're 80 and so I sort of came for the
city of the centenarian Olympics and the
first thing I know about the centenarian
Olympics is it's it's very personal it's
individual everyone will have a
different set of events so you and I
might have a different looking centenary
and Olympics though I think there are
some common things to all so the first
thing I did to figure this out was I for
myself which is you know the person I'm
solving for in the first iteration is
sort of mapped out how old everyone in
my life would be when I'm a hundred so
how old would my kids be how old would
their kids kids be and all the way down
and that gave me kind of a mental model
of what the world looks like when I'm in
my tenth decade and what I realized is
the things that are probably going to
give me the greatest joy at that stage
will involve interacting with those
little or people and my kids won't be
that little they'll be in their 60s or
whatever but their kids will be you know
in their 20s and 30s and their kids kids
will be basically the age of my youngest
kids now and so I just started paying
more attention to what I do with them
and it's stuff that you know Tim you and
I would take for granted that in fact
I'm guessing anybody listening to this
is gonna take it for granted but kids
you've seen my kids a million times they
play on the floor so step one can you
get up off the floor can you lay on the
floor can you do something on the floor
and can you get up under your own
support again you could do that
blindfolded today but watch how many
people even in their 60s let alone 70s
and 80s can't do that and then you start
to deconstruct why what are the
structural misgivings that prevent
someone from doing that
another thing I noticed is how often
toddlers come running at you headfirst
and they don't actually stop when they
get to you so there's an implicit
assumption that is they're running to
you you're going to be able to pick them
up and stop that momentum and if you
can't you're gonna get a headbutt to the
groin so that's that's a very essential
part of the equation here so I started
saying well how many times is my son my
youngest son and come running at me and
how I opened it how often do I have to
drop down into a goblet squat grab him
and pick him up
and so basically listed out 18 things
that I can do today that I want to be
able to do when I'm 90 for example and
those events constitute my centenarian
Olympics and so I'll rattle off a couple
of them but you know a 30 pound goblet
squat again could you do that today Tim
yeah you could do a hundred of those
today but how many 90 year olds can do
that very few walking up three flights
of stairs with 10 pounds of groceries in
each hand and walking down under the
same load again biomechanically that's
not true that's not a trivial task the
walking down has its own challenges the
walking up has its own challenges being
able to pull myself out of a pool where
the gap between the water and the
surface the lip of the you know the SIRT
of the ground is six inches away so
being able to actually like pull myself
up as I said getting up off the floor
with a single point of support being
able to put a 30 pound suitcase over my
head all these sorts of things and would
simulate putting her luggage into the
overhead exactly like again I would not
want to I do I don't wanna get to the
day when I can't put my luggage above
myself in the airplane and once I sort
of mapped out all these things I kind of
broke down what the movement patterns
that were necessary to do this so this
requires the ability to hip hinge this
requires a certain amount of aerobic
efficiency this requires a certain
amount of anaerobic efficiency this
requires a certain amount of scapular
stability etcetera etc and they
basically condensed into four elements
of Health which is stability so the
ability to control you know using the
muscles of the body control
the exoskeleton such that load is
transferred safely through muscles as
opposed to unsafely out joints strength
aerobic efficiency and anaerobic
performance and then you back out of
that and say well if you want to be able
to do all of those things by the time
you're a hundred or say in your tenth
decade so between 90 100 what do you
need to be doing when you're 70 because
there is going to be an inevitable
decline from 70 to 100 and if you can do
this metric at 70 what do you need to be
able to do at 60 and what do you be able
to do at 50 and you know since that's
the decade I'm closest to you know I'll
be 50 soon that becomes my benchmark is
okay so that's what I'm training for and
so this idea we've sort translated to
our patients which is you know unless
you really have a strong desire to do an
Ironman or run a marathon
most people are exercising without a
real sense of purpose and so the
question is could you create a true
sense of purpose around this and then
work backwards to build towards it and
obviously we're not going to know the
answer that question until people start
getting there but my my strong belief is
you can and you should so and if you if
you if you don't do this if you just
assume by chance you're going to get
there I think the likelihood of that is
low and if we look at one of those
exercises and you can pick any one let's
just take the goblet squat yeah goblet
squat to simulate picking up a toddler
how do you back out from doing that at
ninety or a hundred with thirty pounds
do you assume a certain amount of
sarcopenia is that the right we're in
loss loss per year from 70 to 100 and
then somehow calibrate a much higher
weight for a certain number of
repetitions as a result how do you how
do you think through that calculus it's
exactly that so it's not rocket science
to figure out a 30 pound goblet squat at
90 equals how many pounds at 50 the
bigger question is to understand how you
have to do it bio mechanically at 50 to
ensure you can still even do it safely
at 90 so let's just say the number is 90
pounds at 50
it's not that hard to goblet squat 90
pounds for a fit guy like you but it's
actually kind of hard at our age to door
any plays age frankly to do it perfectly
especially with complete scapular
protraction which is another thing you
want to be able to do because remember
you're holding a toddler here so you
need to be completely stabilized through
the upper and lower body and the thing
that's nice about a goblet squat just as
one example you wouldn't just describe a
goblet squat to people for those who
don't know I mean there's he does
kettlebell is an example yeah yeah yeah
so if you're picturing holding a
dumbbell or a kettlebell and you have
both hands on it and it's in front of
you and you're going into a squat
position that way so as opposed to like
a barbell squat where the bar is on your
back and you're holding it back the nice
thing about this goblet squat is it's a
little bit more representative of real
world movement because you now have your
scapula that have to move forward that's
called protraction and you have to be
able to stabilize that position which is
you know going to be holding the you
know the kettlebell or the dumbbell or
the child or if you're our friend Kevin
Rose you want to be able to throw a
raccoon at 90 also helpful for those who
haven't seen it you have to get into it
there's a great video of Kevin wrist
throwing raccoon you can look it up back
to the children on the gobble squad yeah
so and then of course you get into the
real minutiae of what does it really
mean to be able to squat safely and
again for most people myself included
before I was really putting a lot of
thought into this to do a heavy hip
hinge activity like a squat or a
deadlift
you will naturally tend to fall into a
place of lumbar compression you will
compress the spine when you do these
things that's not that sustainable what
you really want to be able to do is get
to a point where you can do those things
under spinal traction which sounds very
counterintuitive most people think of
traction is something you can only
achieve when you hang which is
elongating the spine but it turns out if
you generate concentric intra-abdominal
pressure from diaphragm to pelvis you
can actually stretch out the spine while
you're under load
and once you start doing it
biomechanically correctly at the age of
40 or 50 or whatever and you start to
carry that forward then you're sort of
winning on two fronts with the more
important of those being the time you
get to 90 you actually have the ability
to even move in that direction and
stabilize your trunk which is the rate
limiting step for a squad
it seems it seems like with many of
these movements and I suppose in many
things in life if you want to play the
long game you kind of have to check your
ego at the door right because you would
probably be making some trade-offs in
terms of the amount of weight you can
lift etc if you're going to be training
technically to be able to perform these
movements at 90 right you might have if
you're not going to be doing a wide a
powerlifter squad with a limited range
of motion compared to say an Olympic
asked heels squat very different
mechanics and what you can do I mean I
work with three people a woman named
Beth Lewis a guy named Michael Strom
sness and another guy named Michael
Rantala and then all of them have a
training in something called dynamic
neuromuscular stabilization or DNS and
then they all of course bring in their
own expertise outside of that from
powerlifting and other athletic
disciplines and Beth who's sort of the
one that kind of defaults into my
deadlift program so I deadlift twice a
week and we started from scratch so we
have basically put you know imagined
I've never deadlift even though I
started dead lifting at the age of
fifteen and power lifted all the way
through high school her view is no we're
talking from scratch it's as though
you've never done this before and one
day a week I'm doing straight bar you
know it's a very traditional closed leg
straight bar deadlift and I mean she had
me starting at 105 pounds and I was not
allowed to progress from that for a
couple of months and I was like Beth at
least let me just get to 135 so I can
use the goddamn 45s on the side of this
thing I mean it's getting ridiculous and
she's like no you're not ready yet and
you know so I'm just imagining a row of
like five or ten pounds
at the bar knuckles scraping the floor
so well luckily we had tempers so so we
were just opposing the straight bar
deadlift with very light weight and she
was letting me use more weight on the
hex bar but we had to fix a whole bunch
of movement defects yeah hex bar for
those who don't know also known as a
trap bar so-called in the former case
because it is a hexagon you step inside
of so that effectively the bar path is
traveling through the center line of
your body and so the hex bar is much
easier to deadlift because you are in a
more advantaged position but it's also
easier to do incorrectly and the reason
for that is you don't have a bar in
front of your shins and so if you're
like me you tend to default into a very
quad dominant deadlift and what Beth
realized was we had to break that cycle
and the only way we were going to get
you to use your hamstrings Peter is if
we changed your position and I you know
the the the idea was the best way to
change your position was put a bar in
front of your shins that you can't go
through so anyway that's one example but
yeah it to your point about checking ego
so much of what I do these days in the
weight room looks really silly and it's
not using nearly that much weight I mean
today you should have seen me likewise
today in the gym today was sort of
comical to watch you know a lot of
single arm pressing in you know
positions that are really forcing me to
generate the right amount of concentric
force inside my trunk and uses a
concentric force in the trunk what do
you mean because I'm familiar with
concentric eccentric as thought of say
in a bicep crawl with lifting awake in
this case contracting concentric
movement versus eccentric loss okay sure
like someone putting in yeah yeah
picture somebody putting a balloon
inside your belly let's pretend for a
moment they could strip all your guts
and liver and everything out and you
could put a cylindrical shaped but round
top and round bottom balloon inside your
abdomen so at the top it's mimicking
sort of the shape of your
diaphragm and at the bottom it's sort of
like the shape of your your pelvis and
then the idea is you sort of start to
blow that up and you generate this
pressure that comes out so all of the
muscles are sort of getting longer and
under more tension and that the the
force is sort of uniform all the way
throughout and that that's called
intra-abdominal pressure or I ap and
what I realized over the past you know a
little over a year now is most of us
have lost the ability to put air into
our pelvis or put pressure really is the
right way to think about it you're not
literally putting air in your pelvis the
air doesn't go below the diaphragm but
we don't know how to generate that
pressure in the abdomen and by being
able to do that that's what it enables
you to actually stabilize your spine so
some people who say you know people say
to me all the time I can't believe you a
deadlift like that seems so crazy aren't
there better ways to get the same
activation of the muscles in your glutes
or hamstrings or quads and the answer is
yes and no I mean you can certainly do
those things without having to go under
that load but a deadlift is an amazing
audit as is a squat for that matter and
and I do I think of those things as
audits because if you're doing them
correctly and once you learn the
proprioceptive cues that you're supposed
to feel you know when you're having a
good day in a bad day yeah if you having
a good day that's the feeling you want
to replicate ya audits there are quite a
few movements that act as good on its
Turkish getup also a nice little audit
for another day perhaps
so let's I'm kind of doing the math here
I'm like alright we have 15 or 17 it's
gonna be a long podcast but let's put a
bookmark in the centenarian olympics
which you might come back to you never
know something you've changed your mind
on so the in no particular order of the
order that I listed these things out the
use of metformin in very healthy
individuals is something I've changed my
mind on so I don't think we talked about
this on any of our other podcast success
you know what was the previous the
previous position
or conclusion and then so my 2010 view
which sharpened and became more and more
bullish from say 2010 through 2015-16
was that metformin was a very very low
risk cancer mitigating drug in anybody
now I believed that it was more so in
patients who had diabetes or conditions
that approximated diabetes like
hyperinsulinemia but the data were I
think quite convincing to me and my
extrapolation was well even in people
who don't have diabetes this is still a
great longevity agent and for those who
know what does metformin do well you
know that's a that is a big question
yeah and it's and that's part of the rub
is metformin does a lot of things it's a
mild mitochondrial toxin and this
becomes relevant to the story so it sort
of inhibits the first complex of the
mitochondria what's called complex one
and by doing so and it seems to do so
almost so I mean preferentially in the
liver it leads to a cascade of events
that activates an enzyme called a MP
kinase and when you do that the body
basically starts acting like it's in a
fasted state so it's sort of like a
junior fast and a pill and for people
with diabetes what's beneficial about it
is it lowers the amount of glucose that
the liver puts into circulation so
there's plenty of benefit to that and
that's there's there's no disputing its
efficacy there and in the last five
years frankly it's become a very popular
topic there's I've interviewed a guy
named NIR Barzilai on my podcast and
we've talked exclusively about this near
is one of the world's experts on
metformin and he's leading the charge to
do a very large clinical trial to test
the question of whether metformin is a
longevity drug in non diabetics anyway
the point is my baseline view was that
this is the case and I had been taking
that for
since 2010 what changed a year ago was I
began doing a very focused type of
exercise that was geared towards
mitochondrial performance and efficiency
something called zone 2 training where
you basically push the boundaries of how
much work you can do while keeping
lactate below 2 millimolar so lactate is
a byproduct of metabolism under
conditions in which you're asking the
body to make ATP which is the energy
currency at a rate faster than can be
sustained aerobic ly using oxygen only
so by pushing the boundaries of how much
work you can do and I mean work in the
very technical sense so how fast you
could run how many watts you could push
on a bike and and ratcheting up that
level while still keeping lactate below
to your training your mitochondria to
become more and more efficient and what
I started noticing when I was mucking
around with different drugs was whenever
you have metformin in your system that
that output goes down so and again that
I was mean you thought about it for a
minute that shouldn't be surprising
it's a mitochondrial toxin could you
just don't lose your train of thought
but what our mitochondria so [ __ ]
fascinating but mitochondria really
really interesting we I don't take us
off the rails yeah they do a lot of
things but for the purpose of this
discussion what they do is they do the
most efficient form of energy transfer
which is transferring energy that comes
in the chemical form of energy like food
energy right so when you eat something
like glucose or fat or your body breaks
down and gives you glucose and fat how
do you turn the energy that is stored
within those chemical bonds the
carbon-carbon bond the carbon-hydrogen
bond etc how do you turn that into ATP
and you do that by first breaking those
things down and getting electrons into
these electron donors and people who
might remember from a high school class
something called the electron transport
chain that runs through the mitochondria
and those electron donors eventually
donate back make an energy gradient that
makes ATP and in the
and all they spit out is oxygen ms
carbon dioxide and water so that's why
we breathe out carbon dioxide and water
vapor in exchange for taking food and
making energy so they play an essential
role obviously in in energy production
and if you lose the ability to make
energy with the mitochondria that's
effectively what happens to a cancer
cell so this idea of zone 2 efficiency
is so important for metabolic health
that I started questioning well why the
hell would metformin be a good thing if
it's impairing that and basically after
doing a lot of experimenting with and
without metformin metformin under
different clearance pathways etc etc it
became unambiguous to me that metformin
was impairing this and there was no two
ways about it and then I began to
question well you know how would you
reconcile that with the fact that
metformin is helpful and then you
realize well met Foreman's only really
ever been shown to be helpful in people
who have diabetes and when you look at
the sort of mitochondrial performance at
people with diabetes it's abysmal in
fact even though that's not a hallmark
that the medical system would typically
pay much attention to but if you do that
type of zone 2 testing in people with
diabetes it's such a contrast between
them and someone without diabetes so I
realized well maybe when you are all
when your mitochondria are that sick a
little bit more toxicity doesn't matter
that much but if you're playing a
different game it might now since that
time a number of other studies have come
out I've written about one of them maybe
actually two of them that look at the
effect of mitochondria pardon me
metformin and mitochondrial inhibition
on the difficulty of growing muscle mass
which again is not as interesting to me
but that appears to be a totally
different issue which is the blocking of
sort of the stress response I think the
jury's still out on meaning that it
appeared that metformin appears to
inhibit versus not administration in
metformin correct metformin but let's
write metformin seems to impair the sort
of
the the inflammatory response that would
be pro-growth to muscle Pro adaptation
for lack of a better word I think it's
still too soon to say how this story
shakes out but I was basically in the
past year I've seen enough data to
suggest that for me personally the
benefits of just focusing and doubling
down on my exercise are probably going
to yield better results than the use of
metformin and and of course then the
question is how do you translate that
into patients and where do you draw that
line which patients are sufficiently on
the healthy enough side and I don't know
the answer I think my thinking on that
is the more you exercise and the
healthier you are the less benefit and
potentially the the more detriment you
could experience your metformin I mean I
suppose this is this is not Tim playing
a doctor on the internet but just
thinking about that that even if someone
were say pre-diabetic or presenting the
symptoms of or biomarkers if someone
who's pre-diabetic it might it might
make sense to try other interventions
before metformin right because you might
slap on 10 pounds of muscle mass and lo
and behold they're much better at at
disposing of glucose or any number of
things could change I think no matter
what like if you take somebody who's got
diabetes I don't think people appreciate
how potent a tool fasting exercise and
sleep are you know when you rob someone
of sleep when their sleep sucks when
they're not exercising and when they
have full stores of glycogen in liver
and muscles which is basically the state
you're in when you're constantly fed the
ability to reverse those three things is
is more powerful than all drugs combined
I mean so so I agree if there's a way
that you can treat patients without
using medication one should always do it
sometimes metformin does offer a great
step forward and again it you know it
comes down every patients ability to
sort of you know adhere to exercise and
all these other things
would you ever consider using metformin
maybe this is more job for akribos is
that but using say metformin selectively
when you're going through a period of
over feeding for some period first for
some purpose I mean I think those are
exactly the kind of questions I'm still
struggling with which is does it make
sense to cycle metformin does it make
sense to only use metformin in the
evening but not use it in the morning so
you let's say in the morning you know
you exercise but in the evening when
most people are fed like for one of the
things I did notice when I stopped
taking metformin is definitely my
nighttime glucose levels are just a
little bit higher because nighttime
glucose is controlled by the liver it's
not really a function of what you just
ate it's you know you're so far outside
of that last meal that it's generally
the response of the liver putting
glucose in circulation and titrating
that so yeah I think they're probably
different like you know five different
ways that you could sort of slice this
thing up and decide on how to do it and
I don't know the answer and I guess I
reserve the right to change my mind
again but for now that's been that's
been a pretty big change for me
absurdity stupidity I know we have a a
wealth of options because you and I are
sort of connoisseurs of the absurd so
one of them which is the one that you
already know about and I know you're a
big fan of is boxing I just cannot get
enough of egg box okay so ah God where
do we even go with this because this
could be a podcast in and of itself so
but I don't think we have time to tell
the story if people look it up or we can
link to a video of the the Rama Newton
of egg boxing that's right
but King fine that is maybe a story for
another time which really does put into
concrete terms
just how ridiculously obsessed with
Peter can be but what is egg boxing so
it's a sport slash game where whenever
you're making something with eggs you
you you hold an egg you hold another egg
you bang them off each other the one
that cracks you obviously break and the
one
that didn't crack that consider that's
considered one win so that like let's
say these are two eggs you've never
touched before you smash them that that
guy is now wanna know and then you pick
up another right let's say you want to
make five eggs and you smash and let's
say that guy wins again so he's now to a
no and then you smash again and let's
say he loses well then he retires with a
record of two and one and the other guy
is now wanna know and you keep going and
at the end like when you break your last
egg that day you write down how many
wins the last guy has cuz by definition
the last one standing is always the
winner and then the next time you come
to make eggs you just play again and so
I don't know when I started playing this
game but it was somewhere in high school
and I've never stopped and I take it
very seriously and I guard the champion
very closely and as you're alluding to
we did we did there was there was one
very very special egg in my life in 2007
and 2008 who I nicknamed Rama Newton
after the great mathematician not a
great boxer but he was such a prodigy
honorable boxer yeah but he's the only
egg I've ever had where his winning
record was so great that we'd lost track
of his actual record was it in the
hundreds thousands Oh
I mean put it this way he was the
champion for more than a year now all
right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna continue on to future bullets but
I will say if my memory serves me
correctly then at one point you're like
I want to know what type of strange like
abscess or structural abnormality exists
in this egg but you couldn't get someone
to agree to extract the egg for you see
like snuck it into your pocket well no
the plan was I was gonna go to the ER
and pretend I had a groin injury and
have them do a CT scan of my pelvis with
ramen eating in my pocket
cuz I wanted to see what was really
going on inside of him and alas we shall
never know died a tragic death got an
awful tragic death that I might explain
in the video
okay well link in the show notes to the
video which includes a demonstration of
the proper technique frag boxing and I
don't if you know this but Nick Stenson
who works for me and in the podcast
actually built championship belts for
the eggs oh I saw them because you on
what the challenge is right like that's
right so now we have championship belts
for my eggs and it's one of those things
people always say Peter when are you
gonna start making swag for your podcast
the first piece of swag I would ever
make would be championship eggs like I'd
like that championship belts for their
well you know I I should give you credit
where credit is due you have introduced
me to a number of people who've been on
this podcast and you including Jocko
willing who is a master of merch
no big surprise granted execution and
I'm thinking that you might even be able
to sort of create the equivalent of the
celebrity bobble head dashboard for your
dashboard craze by having particular
personalities represented in the world
of egg boxing you could have a Jacko egg
boxing iteration of some type
you'd have to clear with the big man
himself obviously but I mean I'm
literally gonna call Jocko and actually
this guy loved the idea alright we're
back
I like this cycling through I think we
should go back to excited about okay the
next thing I have on my excited list is
just overall the space of fasting and
the potency of fasting but it's it's
sort of taking a page out of your
PlayBook right so the work that you've
done recently with Johns Hopkins is
basically and I was talking about this
with a bunch of people today at the race
and they were like what is Tim really
excited about these days and I said well
you know and I kind of walked them
through your thesis in context by race
we mean f1 yes here in Austin and if you
don't know anything about f1 just
consider this top cars have what is it
500 million behind them put into them
teams of hundreds I mean it's oh yeah
yeah yeah five hundred million dollar a
year budget easily team of a team of a
thousand so
all right so continue didn't mean to
interrupt so so what I've realized is
and I've vented about this many a time I
in fact I have an entire Sunday email
the devoted just to my event on this
which is it really bothers me that we
don't like if fasting is such a potent
tool and I don't think anybody who's
studied nutrition or biochemistry would
disagree with that it's sort of odd we
don't know how to dose the tool and so
as you know Tim I fast for about seven
days a quarter and this is how it ties
into the Hopkins is the question of
dosing is the question of studying
something is basically taking it yes so
so so it's basically saying okay I fast
seven days a quarter and people ask me
rightfully so but Peter how do you know
to do that like well you know I've you
know someone will say well I fast three
days a month and that's a comparable
number of days total days fasted but
what's producing the ideal physiologic
response that would lead to life
extension or the minimum reduction of
you know disease risk and again it
bothers me greatly that I don't know
that so it sort of occurred to me that
what we need to do is form a little
coalition and a number of my patients
have already said Oh
sign me up I'm in and we'll basically
put a pot of money together and find the
best people who understand and can help
us pick the right animal model because
we're not gonna be able to study this in
humans like you have to accept that you
that were in the option B territory
there is no option a there's no let's do
this experiment in humans and study them
first absolutely because wouldn't get
cleared by the IRB or it would take too
long just textual yeah yeah if you want
a heart outcome which is actual
mortality you have to do this in an
animal model missed that last part yeah
so so should it be mice well you know
mice have the advantage of being really
easy to study and you could probably
know the answer in a year and that might
be the answer but it will require people
really smart to understand what the
equivalents are for mice and fasting and
it's not going to be a linear
extrapolation from our humans like for
example you know a mouse that fast for
two days dies and loses 25% of its body
weight directionally so that's not going
to be that helpful
but I think in ostriches I mean yeah and
I mean I have no idea what it's like
ferrets I mean I just I don't know but
what I really want to do is in the next
couple of years come up with the next
best answer and until that time
unfortunate I'm going to continue to
flail which means I'm going to continue
to fast but do so without much real
insight about what the quote-unquote
best way to do it is or if regimen a is
better than regimen B but I think this
idea of just saying you know what look
NIH is probably not going to fund this
because I don't think there's a question
there that interested in industry is not
going to fund this because you can't
sell a fast you know VCS aren't gonna
fund that like when you look at all of
the traditional funding vehicles that
would go into exploration of question
this one really has to come down to
philanthropy and I have no interest in
like creating an organization to do this
so why not just you know bring a
coalition of people together find the
right people and just directly fund them
what would the study design look like so
let's just say and I get I don't know if
you would do this but let's just say it
was agreed upon that mice would be an
appropriate model and let's just say
that you know you agree that there would
be three arms right one arm would be
mice that were on regular Mouse chow and
it would be important that it would be
proper Chow not nonsense Chow like a lot
of these studies are done with pure
sugar high fat nonsense Chow the goal
isn't to do that the goal is to take
like healthy mice and then picking the
right strain is in itself a huge
decision that would have to go into this
so you have the ad lib feed so these are
the mice that are allowed to eat
normally yeah ad libitum yes mm-hmm then
you'd have problems means they can eat
as much as the one that's right and you
have to be very careful about what that
looks like by the way in animals in
captivity so you you you you still you
might have to actually put them on a
confined number of calories and maybe
it's not ad ad lib and then you'd have
different fasting regimens so you'd have
the equivalent of three days a month
what does that look like maybe that's
I don't know that probably works out to
be something like eight to maybe eight
hours of fasting sixteen sixteen hours
of food exposure I have no idea and then
there's the well what is seven days a
quarter look like or nine days per quart
and those are contiguous days yes yeah
and then maybe you've got the whopper
which is like once a year they just do a
mega fast which for a mouse would
probably be 24 hours and then the idea
would be you know follow them over the
course of their lives and if you pick a
mouse you know pick a bigger mouse
that's like 12 months old at the outset
you'd probably know your answer in about
a year and a half
what would you be what are the outcome
measures or what would you be track the
most important one would actually be
death I say it would be lifespan but you
know if we could gather other indirect
measures disease specific measures if
you know depending on the budget for
such a study if we could also kind of
shotgun and look at some metabolomic
proteomic signals as well that would be
especially interesting because the only
way we would ever triangulate on this in
humans would be to look at biomarkers in
humans that are surrogates of good
things happening so things like etaf
adji the inhibition of senescence cells
reduction of inflammation in you know
areas that we don't really want it to be
in so those would be kind of the two
prongs of this thing which is get the
heart outcome of mortality in the animal
model try to get some biomarker data and
again it's just like I said it really
when you think about how potent fasting
is as a tool that we don't know what the
dose is it's like I've got this thing
it's called Tylenol and I know it
reduces fevers and prevents muscle
soreness how much do I take I have no
idea like think of how frustrating a
problem that is especially with that
example very dangerous problem what is
your current fasting look like in the
sense of timing as a particular day of
the week that you tend to start on
and how do you lead from whatever your
current normal is into the fast so for
the past couple of years I've done the
same thing once a quarter called the I
think it's gonna I think Bob calls it
the kfk nothing burger so it's a week of
Kido that leads into a week of water
only fasting that is sandwiched on the
other end or book ended by another week
of Kido is the Kido hypocaloric is no
clerk it's it's a you caloric ad libitum
keto diet so the purpose of it on the
way in is generating ketones so that
when you enter the fast you suffer a
little bit less the rationale on the way
out is to prevent me from eating like an
idiot sorry which can you relate to that
I generated and we've done a lot of
damage together
I'm just harkening back to our fantastic
trip to Easter Island with I don't think
we said no to a dessert yeah David and
nav two incredible incredible scientists
and they were just appalled and
disgusted because we're so be so well
behaved until we had two or three
glasses of wine and decided you know
what tonight's gonna be cheap night and
the entire table was just piled with
plates of dessert and I'm not ashamed
not shamed but so I am thinking next
year of changing it to three days a
month just as a way to mix things up
it's it'll be a little less socially
intrusive the the week of fasting
becomes a little bit of a grind I only
do it when I'm away from my family and I
always go Saturday to Saturday or sorry
sideways go Sunday to Saturday so I I do
like Saturday and last meal is always a
Saturday at first meal is a Saturday
whereas I was thinking yeah what if I
just did like a Monday Tuesday Wednesday
the first Monday Tuesday Wednesday of
every month or something like that
you know that would be an alternative
way to do it yeah I've done more if
they've done seven day and 10 day but
I've done more of the three day I've
always started on Thursday early dinner
that was all or that was the last meal
because I could kind of gut through I
wasn't doing these but you prefer to be
see I like to be fasted during the week
more than the weekends
I get I can get grumpy depending on the
transition because I'm not doing
generally I'm not doing the ketosis
first I'm not coming into it produce a
much in terms of ketones so I'm going
cold turkey water only let's call it
7:00 p.m. on a Thursday and then I can
kind of gut through Friday especially if
I schedule things such that I'm having
mostly admin like phone calls and so on
nothing that requires any degree of
delicacy or diplomacy I don't leave
scorched earth in my inbox and I need to
unfuck for days afterwards so usually
it's early and then I go water only and
I'll walk a lot on Friday
this goes to a walk and talk with lots
of water and a handful of electrolytes
and so on are you supplementing when you
go water only are you going directly
from ketosis the ketogenic diet into
water only and not supplementing no I'm
supplementing with sodium magnesium
being the two main things are you
supplementing with different types of
magnesium or just a single time yet two
different types during the fast I use
slow mag and I use l3 and eight in the
evening so slow Meg I take two slow Meg
in the morning to slow Meg before bed
along with two magnesium L three and
eight before bed it's the mag teen yes
yeah that's good stuff
the it's really a fantastic product yeah
all right I'm glad I passed ten
different times on investing in the
company those are the best well I mean
when you're awake you're like this this
lank record-setting trout just kept
throwing itself into the boat and I just
tossed it out and then I was like oh
yeah I'm on a fishing trip
shoulda done that
what's what's something else you've
changed your mind on okay this one's a
little heavier I think that the fate of
one's personality may not actually be
set I think I have historically believed
that we are
born with hardwired motherboards and our
personalities are set in stone and
there's no changing them and in
particular I think for me you know you
and I have talked about this a lot I've
never known a time of not being angry
I've just I don't I mean I think I was
probably just a pissed-off fetus is sort
of my I don't think that's actually true
but that's been my belief template and I
don't know I think just a few years ago
I just maybe more than that maybe ten
years ago even fifteen years ago I
remember I'm having this discussion with
my dad once it was really sort of a sad
day because my wife and I who had been
barely married we might have been
married for like a couple of years and
my parents were over and it was just a
minim to him even I'm even too
embarrassed to tell the story but my
wife and I had a fight which was
basically just me being a total piece of
[ __ ] it's in other words it's not even
like there was any symmetry in this it
was just I was 100% wrong
and I dug my heels in and I was such a
jerk and you could sort of tell my
parents were just so sad for us and I
think sad for me at my sort of miserable
existence and I sort of remember my dad
not saying anything but sort of his body
language being like dude like what I
mean what are you doing like why are you
such an [ __ ]
and so I preemptively struck at him
which was look I don't even want to hear
about it man just like I'm not meant to
be around other people you know I just I
just remember going like launching into
this tirade about how I am not really
designed to be around other people like
there's just no two ways about it like
I'm Way too volatile I'm Way too angry
I'm Way too you know all these other
things and I think I've carried that
belief system with me up until about a
year ago up until probably yeah up until
about a year ago maybe a year and a half
ago and I now realize that that entire
narrative is simply incorrect it's no
more correct than saying you know I have
two copies of an ape oe4 gene which is
you know which would be a genetic
template that would make you much more
likely to get Alzheimer's disease but
arguing that it's a given that you're
going to get Alzheimer's disease that's
not the case these are not deterministic
genes and similarly I don't think that
these flaws
in our personality are deterministic and
while there may be people who are more
or less predisposed to be one way or the
other and then of course events in life
can reinforce that and push you more
into that and then the response to that
can reinforce that so all of those three
factors can drive you in a given way I
know this sounds like a very glib
example but I I really think that with
enough work you can start to overcome
these deficits and I think that for me I
think I'm only 50% you know as angry as
I was during my you know sort of anger
heyday and so I know to me that's
amazing like that that because I now I
now have this confidence that I've never
had before which is two years from now I
might only be 50% of what I am today and
that would be 25% of what I was at the
outset so the tracking of the fury half
life yes exactly
so so I just I just think that that's
that's my personal example but for
someone who says you know I'm just not
fill in the blank enough or I'm to fill
in the blank I I do think a lot of us
start to buy our narrative and we just
start to believe the story and for me
that is that is by far the most
hardwired story I've ever believed about
myself there and there are lots of
stories I believe about myself right I
mean we all have our insecurities and
I'm to this or I'm to that or I'm not
this enough or I'm not good enough or
bah-bah-bah
but this this one was like then uh that
one you don't get to change like that's
I color and there's not even a contact
lens you can put on it like it it just
is what it is I've seen certainly and I
mean we talked about a lot of this in
the first episode of your podcast where
you and I had a long long conversation
about many of these things the drive
holding to it but I don't know if I'm if
I if we talked about this particular
perspective on what we might use
deficits or
weaknesses and that is finding a way to
inspect them as coping mechanisms and
protective mechanisms that served an
incredibly important function at some
point right that's exactly right so
instead of refusing and rejecting those
pieces of you may be feeling anger
towards them certainly which I've done
plenty of instead looking at how you
might thank them for mitigating or
preventing even if it ended up being now
counterproductive when overused but at
some point these were responses that
protected you right like if that if that
were the Assumption how would how might
you look at them differently could that
possibly be true and that's been
incredibly important for me and
reconciling all all different types of
fast to myself that I've long held kind
of resentment and anger towards yeah I
mean and we could if we were to really
double-click on this topic that that's
exactly the direction we'd go which is
it starts with a little bit of self
empathy and introspection and
realization of well let's examine the
why this this must have served some
purpose at some point this was an
adaptation to something let's
acknowledge that and you know in the
words of Terrence real who I just
recently interviewed for my podcast you
know it's it's it's taking that adaptive
child in you and thanking them but just
moving them to the back seat like making
sure their hands aren't actually on the
steering wheel yeah
and saying hey like thank you thank you
for for the help you gave me during this
period but I need you to just sit back
there now and just just chill out man
just lay out the window
we're just gonna go on a drive butBut
the adult has to drive now mmm
this is a hard Segway and too stupid and
absurd things but let's [ __ ] force it
money is looking at the stupid thing you
would you would I'll tell you what it is
nothing
it's really funny yeah yeah so the the
next stupid thing on my list is tearing
phone books but I will say it's not out
of rage this is like a wine pairing it
works perfectly oh yeah so when I was in
college a good friend of mine named Todd
Remington one I never forget this I was
at soso it was his wife and my then
girlfriend were like best friends so we
were all the all four of us were at
their place and he came home with a
phone book like a standard two
two-and-a-half inch phone book and he
goes do you think you can tear this and
I in college I was like really strong
right I was like probably not but let me
try and I like you know just whaled on
this thing and of course could not tear
this phone book and then he shredded it
like just well just ripped it in half
and I was like oh my god how did you do
that and he's like you know he
immediately just told me he's like look
it's a technique and he explained the
technique and I was like alright well do
have another phone book he's like no how
was our only one and I was like are we
get more and this was back in the day
when like you had phone books so we I
remember this we got into his Land Rover
or whatever it no he had like a like I
don't know some Toyota like forerunner
4runner that was it yeah and I still
remember we didn't his silver for when
we drove to the mall which was like 20
minutes away and we went into the phone
store because they had phone stores
inside of malls this is like pre cell
phone and they had a wall of phone books
like hundreds of them and I just I don't
know why I like it was just such an
obnoxious thing at me to do I just heard
it grabbing all the phone books and the
woman she goes not a word nothing like
just totally yeah and the woman comes in
says what are you doing and I was like
oh I work at a camp for kids and we do a
lot of paper mache and the phone books
are the best for paper mache and she was
like almost apologetic she's like oh
okay uh-huh
I think I mumbled like it was a camp for
kids that had like less than a week to
live or sometimes so so we leave the
store with as many phone books as two
guys can carry go back to his house and
I practice that night until my hands
Ladd and I could tear phone books and by
the end of that night I was very good at
it and then it became fully pathologic
as an addiction so I could not see a
phone book and not tear it you're like
the Cookie Monster of fun books that is
exactly right it is it was like Cookie
Monster so I remember in college I rode
my bike everywhere and there this was
back in the era of phone booths and
phone books and so any time I rode past
even if I was late for class if I saw a
phone booth I stopped late my bike down
went into the phone booth grabbed the
phone book tore it got back on my bike
rode to class so I just left in my wake
torn the phone books everywhere so
fast-forward a couple of years I'm
applying to medical school I put
together a spreadsheet of all the
factors that go into do into the
decision of where do you want to go what
kind of research opportunities what's
their ranking in the US News & World
Report
what's their success in getting you into
the residence of your choice what type
of this bubble bla bla bla bla what is
the size of the phone book in that city
was one of the columns in the
spreadsheet
it was absolutely a criteria so what was
the sweet spot was it the bigger the
better was it it's not the size it's how
you use it I mean at some point once
you're if your technique is impeccable
and you're strong enough and it really
just comes down to grip strength it's
not like the strength of your biceps or
something like that it's basically how
strong are your hands and how well do
you know the technique you become
limited by hand size so for example I
could never tear the Toronto phonebook
it was simply too big I couldn't get my
hands around it now at some point enough
strength will overcome it I'm sure if
you if I were stronger I could have done
it so the sweet spot for me was about
three inches and so I wanted to moot I
wanted to go someplace where the phone
book was sort of two and a half to three
inches it all things equal or you can
get in some good working sets yes
exactly so so now I'm going I go through
medical school tearing every phone book
inside I just can't stop and I'll
conclude this stupid story by saying
like how it has kind of a funny ending
or not ending but the funny point in the
middle so for I don't actually
member this I only remember this because
she reminded me of it but on the very
very very first date with my wife which
was in Baltimore which we met at Hopkins
were downtown Baltimore and not in like
the pear part where you get killed but
in like kind of a nicer part of
Baltimore and it was that time of the
month or year or whatever when the phone
books were being distributed and so we
went to this dinner called the Sobo cafe
I still remember and as we walked out
there was a stack of like five phone
books on the doorstep of an apartment
building and I said to her like like a
little child I was like do you want to
see me tear a phone book and she was
like no I was like let me show you
and then undeterred so I was like here
try to tear it like my hundred pound
wife is gonna tear a phone book and
she's like I can't tear it smell like
watch well I tore it she's like why did
you tear that phone book I was like
Jordan we do another one
she's like definitely not I was like
I'll show you let me show you the
technique so then I pick up the second
one I tear it she's like okay definitely
don't do that again
of course I tore all five of Panem
successfu dick like that's five people
that didn't get their phone book and and
I always left the haves bitter because
just in case I want to reassess like
it's not you can't find the number in it
but now it's just a bigger mess and yeah
she just reminded me of that like I
don't know five years ago she's like you
were that night like you tore all those
phone books so I don't know I don't know
what was about it we'll say this I'm
nowhere near as good at it as I used to
be like I remember trying to do a couple
of phone books like a few months ago and
it's definitely a technique you have to
stay up to speed on like it the first
one I fumbled on a little bit and the
second one I got after it but uh you
know I would imagine you might want to
do a pre-emptive funeral for phone books
at some point you will have no more
phone books I mean there's a possibility
you'll have to go to that gay Museum of
phone books to even get ahold of
something that you might desecrate with
ripping yeah it's it's I mean I think
that's I think that's probably why I'm
not as good at it anymore I just don't
get the wraps
alright it sounds like you're still
pretty excited about phone books but
we'll have to we'll keep that in the
absurd bucket yes I took this section to
be stupid things I do not stupid things
I did oh nice that's even better
oh yeah yeah no I like present tons
excited about what's next up on excited
about so this is something that you
deserve quite a bit of credit for but
just sort of archery hunting and the
consumption of wild game and again this
it started out totally benign as maybe
I'll just get a bow you know tim has
told me about why he enjoys this and
I've got a bit of a sense of you know
and just for the listeners I guess the
story is it would have been the summer
of 2016 you were getting ready to go out
on a hunting trip the irony of it of
course was it was with a guy named
Jonathan Hart who at that I would get to
know years later yeah founder of great
brand called Sitka yeah excellent
excellent gear yeah unbelievable gear
and after watching you go through that
journey of training for and going on the
hunt I was like you know I might get a
bow it just might be one of those things
you I want to do every you know a couple
of times a month and just to pause for a
second so I also have come to I think
better understand the perfect or more
perfect than I used to understand
cocktail of characteristics that make
something more likely to be your
crack-cocaine of activities well in the
preparation for that it was I mean it's
very methodical very meticulous you have
gear to tinker with alright and it takes
it brings in some degree of mathematics
and physics which you have background in
so there's more to it but continue yeah
so so in early 2017 I call up the local
bowshot performance archery in San Diego
just get real lucky and the guy that
happens to answer the phone
jr. turns out to be a complete obsessive
I mean it turns out everyone that works
there was totally obsessive but jr.
might even take it to another level just
in terms of his technique obsession and
the rest is history as they say and it's
it's now at the point where in some ways
my life revolves around this thing if
you come to our house I mean you have
you haven't been in a while you need to
see what it looks like now yeah I
haven't seen the new ranch it is out of
control I mean we it's like you know
those lifes those huge block targets now
yes you know like the 5 feet by 5 feet
block targets I mean I've got like eight
of those every animal you can imagine
throughout the range and yeah I mean
every single day my morning routine
involves at least one round of 300 so
300 is the scoring system you use on the
paper target when you either either
shoot at the three spot or the five spot
so I get you know I'll I'd like to get
90 shots out of the way first part of
the day at the target and then do the
longer range shooting the 3d target
shooting and and I will say this it a
big part of this is this has been an
amazing tool tying it back to part of
the training a new set of emotional
skills right so there was a day when if
I didn't shoot well that was the end of
the day everything went off the rails
and I've talked about this I think once
even on a post an Instagram post I was
you know kind of opening up about this
which was like even as recently as a
year ago I remember there was a day when
there was something wrong with my bow
that I didn't realize at the time but I
ended up lodging three straight arrows
into the fence so I'm taking long-range
shots but I missed something in my bow
and one two three arrows into the fence
and you can't recover an arrow once it's
in the fence so that's like three arrows
I just flushed down the toilet and I was
so pissed that when I took each of them
out of the fence because you have to
snap them to pull them out of the fence
I then proceeded to snap each one over
my thigh now these are you
450 to 500 grain carbon-fiber arrows
I was welted for a week which you know
if you you basically give yourself like
a Thai kickboxing like kick with each
one of those yeah and you know so you
when you think about the complete and
utter stupidity of that type of behavior
I've now realized archery is always
going to be an amazing teacher because
either you go up there and you just have
this amazing day where you're in this
flow state and everything goes well and
it feels amazing or it's some variation
of not going that way but you get to
practice this skill of distancing
yourself from the narrative that is dude
you suck you suck how can you be so bad
at this you know and all of these awful
stupid thoughts that sort of spiral out
of control so so that's the part of it
and then of course the thing is you know
then once I finally took these skills
into the field and began to hunt and
begin to experience this cycle of you
know what is it like to go into an area
where you have an animal that is a pest
that needs some population control in
the area that we hunt it's so much the
case that that's that the government is
basically killing these animals and just
leaving them for dead or burying them
and you instead get to go and try to use
your skill to do this and then harvest
the animal and then feed your family and
feed yourself I mean is it the whole
thing is just it's such an incredible
experience that has changed many things
about the way I look at food like it's
made it it certainly reduced my appetite
for consuming food that I haven't had
some relationship with and I think my
aspiration is by next year meaning by
2021 to only eat food that I've killed
mmm I think I'll be able to get there by
next year yeah there's a lot that's oh
there's a lot to discuss there it's a
making me want to get back into archery
I do have my gear and only recently
reconnected or I should say connected
with two guys who train here in Austin
which I'm excited about
not for hunts here but at higher
elevation and don't hunt very often in
part because it's been mostly larger
game so you've got a lot of meat
afterwards to keep you busy
oh and her you were on on Joe Rogan's
show and the name of the bird that I
shot just for clarity was a grouse yes
the mountain chicken it's like the the
chuyia stass 'test running mountain
chicken you can imagine so that's what
that was
it's an amazing shot I was happy with
that I was very happy with that yeah
there's a grouse at like 30 yards with
with a bow I was very happy with that
but uh the the the bow or I should say
archery practice also is a really good
audit in my experience like if your
nervous system
if you feel recovered but your nervous
system is not where it should be your
body really tells you with archery at
least in my case like it's it's a it's a
very effective and very fast assessment
tool I agree I think it's an emotional
audit as well I think the you know John
Dudley who is is you know probably one
of the greatest influences on archery
for me people if people are interested
in archery and don't know who John
Dudley is you just need to hit pause on
this one podcast now and go over to John
Dudley's podcast called knock-on and you
know this is a guy who's a world-class
archer who has who also has the skill of
being an amazing teacher so a lot of
people can be world class but they don't
have know how to explain to shucks like
us like how they actually are doing what
they're doing but John is that really
rare intersection of someone who is
exceptional but really knows how to
break archery down and you know his his
teaching is I mean one of the greatest
lessons I learned from him which is
obvious but it's it's really good to
hear it from someone so good is you
can't you have no influence over the
arrows that are not in your quiver you
know so every time you take that shot it
doesn't matter how bad it is it really
you can't do anything about it and
simply worrying about it
increases the probability that that
error that's still in your quiver is
gonna be a bad shot that's good metaphor
yeah what's a big eared you use
currently so currently and why yeah so
currently I'm using the Hoyt rx-3 bow
which I absolutely love you know it's
it's it sounds so stupid and my wife
laughs me when I say this and I'm sort
of joking but not really like I love it
so much it's the only inanimate object
I've ever wanted to sleep with in my bed
like I just like I love everything about
it I just love I love the way it looks
and the way it feels and like I mean
compound bows as you know are just
ridiculous pieces of engineering yeah
it's it's sort of it feels it's just
hard to believe that they've figured out
a way to make something so efficient I
only shoot with a back tension release
what what type is that I use John
Dudley's release called the the nock to
it and the silver back so he has he has
a pure back tension release called the
silver back and then the nock to it is a
it's a it's it has a thumb trigger on it
but you still do it with back tension so
when your thumb is on it and the
rhomboid contracts that's what actually
pulls the thing back but technically you
could cheat with the nock to it you
can't with the silver back the silver
back is a pure back tension release
could you explain the significance of
back tension and and what what that is
if you just kind of paint a picture for
people who are imagining archery so if
you picture your your let's say your
right eye dominant that would mean your
left arm is holding the bow out and your
right arm is pulling the string back now
these compound bows are very hard to
pull back in the olden days you used to
actually pull compound bows with your
fingers and you would release off your
finger today we have a release that
clips on to a little loop on the string
called the D loop and you're pulling on
that release but whether you're doing
that or just pulling on a string you
still need the release to be a surprise
so a surprise release or a surprise shot
as an essential part of archery because
it combats the sort of need of the motor
system of your C NSN motor system to
sort of have this trigger anxiety or
trigger panic well looking at the target
so if you're looking at the target and
you pull the trigger you're gonna have a
less accurate shot than if you're
following the perfect biomechanics and
the shot releases without your knowledge
and so the way to do that is don't you
need to get to a certain equilibrium
with your focus before said surprise
absolutely yes you have to yeah so so
when you think about looking out well so
what are you doing in arch in it with a
compound bow you have two holes you have
the site which is one hole and you have
the peep which is another hole so those
have to be aligned and just if for those
who haven't used compound bow so the
site is going to be if you imagine your
left arm straight now in front of you
the site is going to be not that
dissimilar from say the top the iron
sights on a handgun or something like
this like this you have a site down by
your hand and then you have another hole
that is actually on the string itself
and you're lining those two up that's
right so you have to get those two
things lined up in the site there's a
level like you know the thing you'd hang
a picture where there's something with a
little bubble so the first thing you're
doing is you're getting rear sight front
sight acquisition then you have to get
the bubble level and then you have to
get the pin where you want it to be now
I use a pin that comes in the side
because I have multiple pins in the bow
but if you have a pin at the bottom of
the single pin it's the same idea so
you've now got rear sight front sight
acquisition bubble level pin on target
and then the target is still going to be
moving
that's okay you have to trust the
process if all those other things are
fine and that site that that pin is sort
of moving gently around your target
that's okay what you don't want to do is
try to time that and punch the trigger
while it's there so instead that's where
you're contracting the rhomboid and
being surprised by when the tension is
actually achieved in the trigger yeah
true with a lot of as far as I can tell
a firearm instruction also so that yes
yeah I've never fired a gun in my life
it's no it sounds odd I suppose but
anyone I've talked to who's like a
marksman they'll say the same thing like
there's still a surprise release on the
trigger
oh it's so much to talk about all right
archery
I have seen your playground once but it
sounds like it's expanded all that the
hamster cage has more toys in it now it
sounds like yeah and I'm about to order
like the monster elk Peters menagerie
and holes of death the animated Pet
Sematary
in the back of your house changed your
mind on what else have you changed your
mind ah well this you know in some ways
sorts of sort of builds off the last one
a little bit but it's basically this
idea that that that childhood
experiences can matter in ways that
after the fact seemed sort of irrelevant
so so that's not the belief that you
have reversed that's the current yes
that's correct
the current belief is yeah so it's all
rephrase it I used to believe that the
you know traumatic events in your
childhood probably weren't that relevant
or could be net positives if they you
know in it this is effectively like a
parallel to the first thing to the
previous one we talked about about
personality stuff
I think what I've come to realize
through you know extensive interaction
with experts in this space my own
experience the experience now of many
people that I know is if a child
perceives helplessness even as an adult
if you look back and think that wasn't
so helpless it you have to be thoughtful
about what the implications and
ramifications of that are going forward
right so you know for example let's take
an extreme example if a child loses a
parent when they're young you might say
well look they have another parent that
other parent has a loving parent
everything is going to be fine but
there's an enormous amount of chaos
that's inserted into that person's life
and if a child perceives that as as like
helplessness
that can really shape the the subsequent
years of their life that can shape
aspects of their personality that I
don't think I have I really understood
and appreciated before and I've seen
this now with a number of my patients
for example using that example patients
who lost parents when they were very
young seven years old eight years old 12
years old suddenly and or tragically or
not suddenly or tragically I mean a you
could have someone who's you know
suffering for three years with cancer
and it's not sudden but it's still to a
child they perceive things differently
an extension of that which comes back to
this whole thing around anger and this
was part of my motivation to sort of
begin to make sure I wasn't so angry was
I almost never got angry at my kids
right but my kids saw me angry so you
know the last time I got really really
pissed in front of my kids was a year
ago and I remember this very well we're
actually driving to a funeral of the
mother of one of my daughter's best
friends so there's a young woman woman
who's you know in her 40s who dies of
cancer and we're going to the funeral it
was exactly a year ago so it's not a
happy day and so it's me my wife and my
daughter going to the funeral and I'm
driving and you know traffic is sort of
moving along at a sort of slow pace and
there's a merging lane that's coming on
and there's this woman who's not paying
even a modicum of attention to what's
going on she's on her phone or something
and then at the last minute she just
goes like accelerates jumps in front of
us I almost hit her and I mean normally
that would be annoying but on that day I
went ballistic
now she didn't even hear me right she's
in another car but the torrent of just
you know profanities and like what I
wanted to do to her and say to her and
bla bla bla bla bla was unbelievable
heightened presumably the fact that I
was just in this awful mood about other
stuff whatever I never for a moment
would have realized like that could have
an effect on my daughter
it's like I'm not yelling at her I'm not
yelling at my wife I'm not like you know
I'm yelling at some random stranger in
front of us but I realized that kids
internalize that stuff different kids
and you know my daughter's not a baby
but she's still a child they internalize
that type of stuff as it's still like
it's still hitting them right so I don't
know I don't I don't feel like there's
still shrapnel that is hitting them in a
way it wouldn't hit an adult and so you
take an extreme that's very mine you
take an example it's very minor like
that one versus something that's very
major like the funeral we were going to
which is for her friend's mom I I don't
think we are paying enough attention to
how these things that kids experience
can shape their personality and so and
to be clear like these are two-edged
swords there are some good things that
can come from hard experience as I'm not
suggesting everything is negative but
you don't have to throw the baby out
with the bathwater right you can accept
some of the positives that come from
these things without ignoring the things
that need to be mended or repaired so I
think that that broad topic is something
that I have really been much more
attentive to both in myself and in my
patients and in understanding their
their lives and their emotional health
as it pertains to the events of their of
their childhood speaking from my
first-hand interactions with you you are
and we talked quite a bit or just text
stupid jokes to each other at least that
with fair frequency and you you you are
much less anger ridden and then you have
been historically which is really nice
to see and I mean it's something that
I've battled with a lot my self also
quite possibly for similar reasons there
are some similar reasons but what
resources or tools if any I don't there
any books or anything else that you
would recommend
or simply mention as having been
valuable for defusing the default anger
response or helping you to revisit the
story of that being and in alterable
aspect of your personality I think there
have been a lot of things there's no one
thing which isn't to say that for others
one thing couldn't do the trick I think
the good news is if somebody's listening
to this and they're also thinking to
himself man like I just wish I was a
little less angry too I think the good
news is the probability that you were
walking around with as much anger as me
is is hopefully low you're probably
starting from a better place and
therefore maybe your anger is less
recalcitrant to change there were many
things so I'll start with one meditation
has made a big difference not by itself
meditation simply gives a gap that's
that's the only thing meditation does is
it creates a pause between the stimulus
and the response and that gap used to
never exist that gap I didn't even know
it was a gap so it was it was a it was a
potential space that I didn't realize
had the potential to be a space which
meant stimulus you know woman cuts you
off while you're on the way to worst
funeral you could be imagining going to
blowing up that's happening in
microseconds not in milliseconds well
the difference is today because that
stuff I mean that still happens every
day like some stupid thing will happen
that would have normally fired me off
the difference is now I have seconds to
inspect that and look at the template of
beliefs that are feeding into that and
examine the why which is what like what
is anger right I mean so so that's that
so that if that's the if the first thing
is using a practice of capacity'
meditation to create a tool in the mind
to slow time down then the second one is
and is that start to to jump in but just
for specifics I know that you and I both
used Sam's waking up ah do you do you
now meditate
without that what is the practice no I I
I use either Sam's or Dan Harris's I go
back and forth tensing them and yeah so
sometimes I'll do like a month on one
and not see the other one and vice versa
I sort of go back and forth with no with
no rhyme or reason the Harris twins so a
bit unrelated yes exactly
the brothers Harris no relation so so
yes just having just just hang and I can
think of a million analogies it's like
imagine you know being a race car driver
and you get to see time travel half as
fast as the other drivers well you're
gonna be a much better driver like you
see the road coming at you at half the
speed the second thing is just work
through through really helpful therapy
has been actually examining what is what
what anger stems from so I think you
know the first time I was ever you know
I want to say forced to or suggested to
play the game of emotional check-in I
didn't have a vocabulary so the question
was how do you feel right now
pissed off okay same or how do you feel
[ __ ] pissed off how do you feel so
[ __ ] pissed off that if you [ __ ]
ask me again I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
like that was the only response I had
right what I didn't have at the time was
I didn't even have a vocabulary to
understand I'm hurt I'm sad I feel
helpless I don't feel in control so so I
had to learn a new vocabulary and start
to learn what those other things looked
like so that I could in that gap of time
start to say oh you're feeling X but
you're you you have such a you have such
a beautiful default wide lane highway
that turns X into anger and oh by the
way yours turns Y into anger and yours
turns Z into anger too like that's
Peters thing other people might have you
know depression or sadness or anxiety as
these other well-worn paths that come
out of these various converging stimuli
so so learning how to recognize what was
understanding that has made a big
difference another thing has just been
you know traditional insight related
therapy you know I mean so Esther Perel
who actually met through you many years
ago who is you know an incredibly
important part of my life today I'll try
to think oh I know what every joke oh
you get one Esther Perel so I'll give
you another I'll tell you the last time
I actually lost my ship I thought it
wasn't a year ago there was a year ago
was with that that funeral it was more
recently than that it was when one of
our chickens got killed and so I'm up
actually shooting doing my archery and I
hear my daughter like kind of scream
like something's wrong and I kind of run
down and she's crying and I see one of
our chickens is mangled into like a
million pieces and of course I
immediately figure out what's going on
and you know had just lost one like I
don't know a month earlier I thought I
had reinforced the coop as much as
possible but clearly I hadn't done a
good enough job and I just went off on a
tirade I mean again I'm embarrassed to
even say all the things I said cuz it's
so stupid I'm basically yelling at
whatever animal that is no longer there
that killed our chicken about what I'm
gonna do to it I mean I guess we can
laugh at it it's so ridiculous though
right what Esther was able to point out
was was let's deconstruct that whole
situation so first of all why are you
angry well if I'm gonna be brutally
honest about it I'm angry because I feel
inadequate
I failed like I'm my job is to protect
my family and my chickens are now a part
of my family like I failed at protecting
these chickens like it can't be that I'm
actually angry at the Bobcat for being a
bobcat like marcus aurelius once said
something along the lines of you know to
be you know it's like being angry at a
fig for making fig juice or something
like that or like a fig tree for growing
figs or something I think so so no
there's no way I'm pissed at the actual
Bobcat who killed the chicken that's
called the site that's that's like the
carbon cycle like that's the way it
works I'm
that myself I have failed to protect my
family I feel helpless but with all
these other things but the point is in
that moment I'm I missed an opportunity
to console my daughter I was so consumed
with my own rage and my own like an rage
as you can probably relate to in many
people who get angry can relate to is a
very suit it's a very numbing
transiently numbing thing
lots of dopamine gets secreted in that
outburst that actually makes you feel
bit better now that doesn't last long
there's a very hollow I think there's a
saying about the it's like a honey with
a poison tip or something like that you
know it so it's a very short-lived
transient benefit that comes with a long
tail of misery but I lost an opportunity
which was my daughter's actually very
upset about this I mean like you know
not only there are chickens give us eggs
but like the kids love them they play
with them every day they all have names
they all have like we know everything
about every one of those chickens and
their personalities isn't it's no
different than her losing her cat or her
dog and instead of consoling her like
I'm wrapped up in my own nonsense so
sometimes you just actually have to be
confronted with that type of brutal
truth and again if you go back to the
first thing which is you now have a gap
the next time a couple months later
something came up it wasn't related to
the chicken but it was something where I
think the Peter of old would have gone
right down the default pathway of just
raging I had a little had that breathing
room to notice the feelings of another
person and realize wait a minute the
much more important thing to do here is
make sure that person is okay and not
you know go down your own stupid rabbit
hole another tool that I think has been
very important here you know Ryan
holiday recently put out and I'm sure
it's still available a whole work like a
whole sort of 10 day or 11 day course on
anger Ryan writes about anger a lot and
I've talked with him about this actually
on in my interview of him really
recently which probably by the time this
is out will not even be out yet but
those types of exercises are helpful
again it comes down to this idea that
once you accept that this is not
something you are hardwired to like your
height or your shoe size and you can
start to change it you just have to
start working at it
so there are a number of other tools as
well I think a lot of this sort of David
Foster Wallace relational reframing
stuff also has been just incredibly
helpful so there is an audio recording
of his commencement speech this is water
that you listen to on a regular basis
yeah to this day I still listen to it at
least once a month yeah usually more
than that so people can can find that in
the show notes I'll put that in the show
notes as well for you at this point in
time what do you think what are the
characteristics of a therapist who is
good for Peter I'm curious because I
have historically and I've largely
gotten over this but had a skeptical
view of most therapists and you come
from a math background you come from a
hard science background and also the
experience of a surgeon where a
pass/fail or an A+ versus a c-minus is I
would imagine pretty tangible and easy
to assess right psych if you if you're
doing reconstructive surgery and the
person's nose is on the side of their
head well yeah you don't [ __ ] pass go
do not collect the money and with
therapy it is a softer in some respects
or actually I wouldn't even say softer
it's a harder field to assess at least I
have viewed it that way how do you how
do you how do you wrap your head around
that how do you think about I mean
that's a that's a great question and I I
don't have an answer I mean I have my
answer but I don't know that that's the
answer almost assuredly is not in the
end two things have to be firing right
there has to be the connection and
chemistry between you and the therapist
or between like I'll just talk about me
I have to be able to connect
that person which is and and for me that
means that their insights have to be
such that I exit almost every session
thinking wow like I see something I
didn't see before I love that so and
then so that's the sort of short-term
tangible like that insight is that's
that's is that's surprising that's the
point where first of all I journal in
the sessions a lot and I sometimes even
record the sessions that's how powerful
I find some of these insights to be
where I can't even capture them all if
I'm there without those tools this but
the but the second thing that matters to
me is the results you know in the end
none of this stuff matters if it's not
reducing your suffering and that's sort
of I mean I use that term very
deliberately instead of if you're not
happier because I don't exactly know
what happiness means but I do know what
suffering means and I do know what it's
like to suffer less and anything that
helps me suffer less which is quite easy
for me to assess is a good thing and so
if I feel that there's this connection
chemistry and constellation of insights
that are constantly you know evolving
from the discussions and it's
translating to a phenotypic benefit
that's result it is the most [ __ ]
Peter it's a way to describe this ever
phenotypic benefit don't worry folks I
don't get it either two things that
matter so in other words like you know
there's other little things like I think
for me the therapists that are really
valuable are also the ones that you know
frankly just don't have a hard time
telling you when you're wrong you know
they just don't have a hard time telling
you you're totally full of [ __ ] and
diluted or that you're being a dick yeah
I mean you know I mean I've had you know
so I have three main therapists which
sounds like they're ridiculous but I
think what you're trying to solve some
of my issues but you know Esther and
saying a pit crew yeah exactly
Esther
and Terry and Lori and I mean I have had
some really brutal sessions with Lori
and I don't know why it's worked out
that way like each I had they all know
each other by the way very well so it's
another thing there's no it's not a
counterproductive experience because the
three of them know each other and they
all know they're chipping away at
different pieces of things but it's
great I've had some very difficult you
know interactions with with her where
you know she has just said to me like
you are being a spoiled little baby you
know like do you do you see what your do
you see what your how you're behaving
right now and I just I think the fact
that she can do that matters a lot I
think there are a lot of people that
would give me a pass on stuff because
it's easier to it's hard to stand up to
someone yeah I think you need are needs
a strong word but I certainly when
interacting with specialists upon almost
any type I prefer people who can fire me
very easily I mean because then it makes
it a lot easier for them if they're in
demand or are completely utterly
concerned with how many billable hours
they're racking up that they can be like
you know Peter you're making this really
[ __ ] difficult for both of us I just
want to like pause for a second to how
you don't like wallow in how [ __ ]
unnecessarily difficult you're making
this is egg okay oh yeah which yeah I
think I think I'm probably also the
problem child
often times so we were on so I think
we're now into stupid things again all
right let's do it
stupid things so to this day I still
play a game called forks and knives
what's and forks and knives his name of
the game so I like so I have an awesome
system with my wife which is she likes
to put stuff in the dishwasher and hates
to take it out I hate putting stuff in
the dishwasher and I love taking
I just I don't like that chunk dirty
stuff I really like clean stuff and I
don't know why she doesn't like taking
it out because that seems more enjoyable
but anyway um and as a kid this game
started when I was a kid my mom says
like I was the best at chores like my
brother and sister apparently didn't
like doing chores as much as I did but I
loved chores I was like her little
helper so whatever she said to do I
couldn't wait to do and one of my chores
was doing the dishwasher and I loved it
so this started when I was probably like
about 8 and I remember she used to
always say Peter can you put away the
forks in the knives and it really kind
of got to me because I was like why
don't you also include the spoons in
that discussion it's not just forks and
knives it's forks and knives and spoons
and she would be like acknowledge that I
said that but you know the next day
she'd forget and she'd be like can you
please put away the forks in the knives
so I was like I'm gonna just start
keeping track and so I played this game
where I would count the forks and the
knives and the spoons and the game is
where the spoons would win any time
there were more spoons and forks and
knives now if anyone who's played this
game and I'm guessing the answer is
nobody
the number in the dishwasher yes that
your remove it yes okay so I basically
every time I got to do this it turned
into a game of who's gonna win the forks
and the knives or the spoons such as a
counting that's good just a counting
game but I was always rooting for the
spoons because they're the underdog
because the probability of the spoons
winning is very low you generally have
way more forks and knives combined than
spoons so over the years the game
evolved and I started to allow other
things to be proxies for spoons so if
there was like a spatula or a carrot
peeler that would get to go in the spoon
category just to sort of level the
playing field a little bit handy
Kathleen yeah you had to handicap this
thing somewhat but the game started you
know almost 40 years ago and to this day
I mean just two days ago I played forks
and knives versus spoons and I love it I
love the and it's at the point now where
I don't want anybody else to put that
stuff away so let's say like Jill is
putting stuff away I'm like no I want to
get the forks and knives I gotta get the
spoons don't win much yeah it's a sad
state of affairs if you're a spoons fan
if they win once every three months like
it is freakin awesome it just feels so
good when the stones win what is the
farthest you've stretched the label of
spoon like what what can you think of
anything that we're there was there is a
big inquiry came in to the rule
committee about 20 years ago where I
thought if I could start including cups
as spoons because they you could you
could see how you could create sort of a
post hoc analysis that would suggest
that well a cup sort of holds things
like a spoon holds things you could
drink soup out of a cup just as you
could use a spoon but I decided that was
a very slippery slope and I didn't I
didn't want to take the game down that
room I thought that was gonna really
tarnish the sport that I loved so much
so I decided I would rather lose 90
times out of 91 times but know that that
one time I want it was the sweetest
victory
this is seem gonna seem like a complete
non sequitur but that as you were saying
this the Rules Committee I'm thinking
about doping in sports and then I
started thinking about this conversation
we had long ago about xenon gas if you
remember this did you end up ever
looking more closely at xenon gas yeah I
so funny you remember that I actually
called what's the name of the company
err gas and I think it's called Praxair
like the track say yeah and basically
the deal died when I just couldn't get a
reasonable supply of xenon gas
reasonable meaning like enough for me to
use I basically had to buy enough to you
know provide xenon gas for the entire
universe and this and the speculation
was that or maybe it wasn't speculation
maybe had been confirmed I can't
remember because I don't know how you
would track such a thing but or maybe
you just have to catch them inhaling but
it was being used by endurance athletes
at the Sochi Olympics yes it was
basically a legal PE D and this was
probably six years ago and at the time I
was still you know competing and cycling
and I was like well like you know I was
comfortable with the safety profile it
was legal and it was enhancing
performance so I was like I want xenon
gas I want to want to take a big bong a
xenon gas
every day before I go and work out are
there any other currently legal
performance-enhancing drugs that you
think the cat-and-mouse game of dopers
and anti-doping committees have not yet
or I should say the not sure which is
the cat which is the mouse against the
cat is the the IOC and so on has not
caught up to where things are that are
simply difficult to test for well the
latter definitely growth hormone fits
into that category so growth hormone is
clearly banned by whadda you sada and
every entity out there but it's very
difficult to check for because it's a
human recombinant equivalent and unlike
something like testosterone where you
can give somebody testosterone but you
can even though it's bioequivalent you
can if you're getting it from the
outside of your body
other things change inside your body
that become a signature of it whereas
that's not quite as easy to do with the
growth hormone now this i would a
signature in this case be would it be
looking at a ratio of what is it yeah
yeah and if you take enough of it
obviously you'd see inhibition of
luteinizing hormone follicle-stimulating
hormone things like that so no I'm not
close enough to it at all I don't I just
don't you know it's it's been it's been
a long time I mean one thing that I did
notice just through some sort of
personal interactions I've had with
professional athletes who are also
interested in sort of mind-altering
drugs is psilocybin is not banned by
wada and MDMA is and I sort of find that
hilarious because I don't think either
of those things have a
performance-enhancing like I mean MDMA
would be a performance great for a bit
great for a greco-roman wrestling yeah
it's like I can't think of one sport
that gets better with MDMA so I was sort
of amazed to see that on the water list
if you went very high dose what is it
methylenedioxypyrovalerone
I don't know what is the term for the
eye movements that are so often
characteristic of higher dose MDMA use
it's like a Stig Mia I can't remember
the term but it would definitely not be
good for something like archery where
the eyes effectively do this back and
forth kind of ratcheting movement I
can't remember the term somebody hold
sure pointed out when they hear this
yeah
psilocybin is an interesting one that
that's that we could certainly delve
into just from it's like many things
better get the dose right if you're
thinking of using it as a
performance-enhancing or an in truce you
know I have talked to people who have
said at very low doses psilocybin has
actually enhanced their physical
performance so so who knows maybe there
is something to that
for I've heard the same from endurance
athletes using relatively or I know not
relatively low doses of LSD I think 10
or 15 micrograms or maybe even tend to
take 25 Wow but it's hard to believe
like it seems so imperceptible like that
seems like such a small dose does indeed
yeah I mean this this upcoming weekend
by the time this comes out it will have
passed but there's the psychedelic
science event here in Austin with maps
in one of the sessions is specifically
focused on Mike reducing which this
would fall under the umbrella of at 10
to 15 micrograms all right we're aren't
we excited we're back to excited yeah oh
yeah well do one it will do one or two
more let's let's go excited
next thing I'm pretty excited about is
just driving you know just sort of
getting deeper and deeper into the craft
of learning how to drive a racecar and
and sort of just you know training both
in the simulator and actually on a
racetrack with a with a racecar and
again I think part of it is I just I
love you know I I love mechanical things
I love cars I love driving them fast and
there's no better place to do that than
on a racetrack but also part of it is
it's another one of these audits you
know like archery it is not a sport that
gets better the more pissed you are it
is not a sport that gets better the
harder you squeeze
so and it's also a sport where let's say
you miss an apex on a turn if you think
about that or dwell on it anymore it
only increases the likelihood you're
gonna miss the apex on the next turn or
miss your breakpoint or miss your
turning point or do something wrong so
it it's one of these things that teaches
us skill that I just think is good for
life which is you don't want to not know
that you made a mistake because then you
run the risk of making that mistake
again but you can't beat yourself up for
making that mistake so you have to have
a relatively short half-life for
torturing yourself otherwise you will
spiral out of control and it's really
amazing I just happen to be very lucky
to have a great coach guy by the name of
Thomas Merrill in driving and I don't
know he's just he's so good at spotting
when my mistakes start and it's never
really the case that when I screw
something up at you know turn seven
where I went off to I was the first
screw-up yeah not even close he's like
actually look at what you did it turned
five and then look at how that fed and
it turned six about time you got the
seven it was he said look the only way
you were not gonna crash at seven is if
you had slowed down enough to a speed
much slower than you would normally go
there because of the mistake you made in
five and six yeah so I think for a lot
of people again it's easy to look at
what people are doing in a racecar and
not think there's much to it but of
course like many things the further you
are from the shore the deeper the ocean
is pop kaplan says and so the more I do
it the more I appreciate the gap between
me and Sebastian Vettel and you're
wearing an Ayrton Senna shirt as we
speak and for those people who don't
know who that is you should absolutely
watch a documentary called Senna mmm-hmm
which is just incredible which which I
think helped me at least as someone
who's completely naive to race car
driving to develop a high level of
appreciation for just how hard it is to
perform at a high level in those
circumstances
yes and how incredibly dangerous it was
at that point in time things have
changed quite a bit but when he was
racing certainly far more dangerous yeah
in the in the 60s
uh you know I would say sort of mid
early to mid sixties into mid 90s it was
a staggeringly dangerous sport
unacceptably so I did something occurred
to me that I don't think I've ever asked
you before and that is have you
considered maybe you already have
something that fits this bill but
picking a hobby or something to obsess
about that is a group activity our
partner activity because it seems like
most of the things I find you gravitate
towards and become very obsessed about
are even though there might be other
humans around they're mostly solitary
experiences yeah you're not the first
person to ask me this and I think it's a
great point
I suspect the problem is I love these
things I do so much I barely feel like I
have as much time as I want to do them
but it might be the case that as my kids
get older and I can do more of these
things with them or or different things
with them that that would sort of
scratch that itch but there's definitely
something to be said for I mean I think
ever since I was 13 I've been so that
was sort of a turning point I think in
my personality or something where I just
remember really gravitating towards
individual things for a whole bunch of
reasons I could probably unpack that I
think that could be an entirely separate
podcast so racing changing your mind I
would say the next one here on this list
would be and this is gonna sound almost
silly but on the changed my mind on the
benefits of exercise being much greater
than I ever envisioned so yeah I would
probably classify
as a borderline exercise addict so for
me to say I now actually think exercise
is incredible and has all these benefits
is sort of a funny statement which is
not to say that I didn't think it had
benefits before but I don't think I
understood or appreciated metabolically
so if you just take one example probably
like four years ago three years ago I
had one of our analysts do this exercise
that took him about a year which was
with some direction around where to
start
comb through all the literature on
Alzheimer's disease and get a sense of
what tools in the toolkit would be most
beneficial to prevent it or reduce the
risk of it and or delay it and you know
I mean it was anything was enough
anything was on the table what drug what
supplement what this with that and he
came back and said and we had a
framework that was a very mechanistic
framework he came back and said it's
definitely exercise and I was like dude
that I mean that sounds like such a
politically correct thing to say come
back with like a real answer please like
that's just sounds dumb it's exercise
like how could it be exercise and of
course it you know he came back and made
the case and in the end I believe that
case which is when you look at what
exercise does from a vascular standpoint
from a growth factor standpoint you know
the creation of BDNF brain-derived
neurotropic factor I really believe that
then again you shouldn't take the view
that you should only do one thing but if
you're if you're really committed to
brain health you you want to be
exercising every day what parameters are
there on that exercise when you say
exercise for instance there are people
that view running as cardio but then you
in the case of resistance training are
obviously utilizing the vascular system
in your heart but how do you think about
type and dose so the literature is not
crystal clear on that but if you loosely
take three types of exercise which is
modest or low intensity quote unquote
cardio
high-intensity cardio and
strength-training if you took those as
the three legs of the exercise stool the
good news is they all appear to increase
BDNF they all appear to have benefits
though two different degrees on vascular
tone circulation etc what I basically
decided a couple of years ago or maybe a
year ago was in the absence of better
information just having an aportfolio
approach to those in the context of the
training for the centenarian Olympics
was the best of both worlds so in other
words my training is programmed through
the centenarian Olympics which requires
that you have training a very specific
type of training in all three of those
legs
coupled with the table top which is
stability so you have these four pieces
of training stability strength aerobic
and anaerobic and by doing these every
day or some combination of them every
day you also know that to at least to a
first order approximation you are
getting the benefits of brain health and
then of course I mean well bridged on
that topic I think sleep and you know
periods of nutrient cycling and
obviously the appropriate steps on
nutrition nutrient cycling meaning fast
and famine yeah I think some pieces yeah
great name for a podcast about fasting
faster famine right feast feast or
famine but it's funny like you know if
you think about Silicon Valley right now
right like everybody's so obsessed with
this no tropic and that no tropic but
but I don't think people understand is
correct nutrition exercise and sleep are
far better nootropics than modafinil I
mean no definite modafinil might be one
of the most potent no tropics out there
but it's actually not that strong and no
tropic it's actually kind of a weak know
tropic actually by the literature it is
pretty amazing how many narcoleptics are
Olympic level sprinters though
prescribed modafinil anti narcolepsy
drug true story Wow eight of the ten top
eight of the top ten or narcoleptics who
would have thought that's how they get
so much time to Train back in the good
old days
what are things and I know you're a fan
uh correct me if I'm wrong but of Matt
Walker and a lot of his thinking on
sleep and I shouldn't say thinking I
mean his research related to sleep how
have you changed
or better yet improved sleep protocol
things that you prescribe not
necessarily chemicals to patients to
improve sleep quality I mean this sleep
is a hard thing because it's sort of
like exercise in the sense that you
can't just give somebody a pill that
makes sleep better it really comes down
to changing its you you have to sort of
accept your gonna make behavior change
you have to prioritize this thing and
it's not just the eight hours you want
to spend in bed
it's the build-up to it so my sort of
simplest toolkit which is what I
basically employ I mean most nights I
don't require a supplement to sleep
that's not like I'm taking you know
melatonin or even using Kirk parsley
supplementing those things I'm basically
reserving for jetlag situations and
things like that but if I'm if I'm doing
everything correctly or fasting you know
that's another time when you need a
little bit of a boost but if I'm doing
everything correctly you know using the
right amount of blue light blocking
glasses and I've recently switched to a
new brand that that I am freakin super
jazzed about it's I mean I find first of
all they actually have published
research that you know documents Eischen
I don't know if it's been published yet
but anyway they they have data that I've
actually seen that demonstrate you know
how much they're able to block blue
light and at least according to my my
sort of sleep tracking metrics they're
they're definitely contributing to much
more deep sleep than I've seen
historically can you name yes yes it's
called Felix grey and he Li X yes Felix
and then gray actually you can see the
box right sitting over there so those
glasses sitting right over there are my
Felix greys and they're they're just
redonkulous gr while people can find it
a Y or anyone yeah yeah yeah I think
it's anyway
and so so you know I'm very religious
about using those things
Felix gray is that a real person or is
Ashley Madison yeah it might be in the
latter yeah say so I use those things
religiously
I'm very attentive to how much light is
around me as the Sun is going down
I'm also very attentive of not doing
stupid things in the evening we've
talked a lot about this not looking at
email not looking at social media not
looking at things that are gonna
potentially activate or phosphorylate me
in any way
it's another Piter Piter ism don't
[ __ ] phosphorylate me also just being
very consistent in bedtime and wake-up
time you know and then and when when I'm
really in the zone it's it's early to
bed early to rise so understanding your
own chronotype are you an early or late
Khurana type we you and I have talked
about this a lot
incredible darkness in the actual room
at night or using I use this thing
called the Alaska bear eye shade it's
like you can buy it on Amazon it's eight
bucks it's like this little silky Alaska
bear it's the stupidest name ever I
don't know why I love it though I have
20 Alaska bears because I have them
everywhere so that I'm never without one
and I use ice I just upgraded in the
last six months from the chili pad to
the cooler that's ool yeah Kevin you
know our buddy Kevin uses that as well
yeah I have no affiliations with any of
these companies by the way so I feel
totally happy to just plug them
shamelessly for no personal gain and the
Euler is a big step in the right it's
it's really taken the chili pad to
another level
first one's on me another I do take
sponsorship money yeah but this has come
up with Kevin that's a joke people in
case you can't take it [ __ ] sake yeah
this has come up a couple times recently
the other thing is almost elimination of
alcohol so I'll probably have a drink
tonight right we're going to dinner like
a bunch of friends get them together in
Austin tonight I mean I'll have a drink
tonight probably you
you were the one who really put it on my
eye I certainly academically or
intellectually understood that alcohol
even though it in some cases seems to
make it easier to sleep really disrupts
quality of sleep or degrades quality of
sleep I really didn't have an
appreciation of that until and this is
one where I guess I don't have any
disclosure but the where the aura ring
really highlighted that for me just how
[ __ ] my sleep was in terms of quality
after say two and a half three drinks
yeah I mean I'm I'm down to probably
three or four drinks a month that's
that's basically it and and and there
I've gone two months without a single
drink it's like it has to be worth it
because even at one drink I'm going to
experience some degradation of sleep and
what would type of degradation it's
generally a reduction in REM for sure a
slight reduction in deep and an increase
in fragmentation so your innate you're
just you're moved into that stage one
stage two space a bit more do you see a
spike in for lack of a specificity the
middle of the night in resting heart
rate after you drink two or three drinks
well I see a higher resting heart rate
period and a lower heart rate
variability for sure and a higher body
temperature and I don't know the last
time I had two drinks in a night but but
definitely it's one to two is also a
really big step up so you know look it's
everyone's got to decide what they're
gonna do and what their priorities are
not here to say don't drink at all but I
just I just I do I would just say like
don't be mindless and you're drinking
it's sort of my point like if you're
gonna drink like make it really freakin
worthwhile I like to do it for a reason
don't just do it cuz the alcohol is
there is it I don't know if you've seen
anything anecdotally or experienced this
personally is it is it just the ethanol
or is there is there variability across
vehicles for you know the alcohol itself
right is it is a sipping too
kela gonna do less damage than sort of
the equivalent blood alcohol content of
juice or red wine or something like that
out of you if you've looked at any of
this yourself
I mean anecdotally it's hard to know
because your mind is also sort of
feeding into a narrative around the
stuff but certainly drinking my clase
azul Reposado seems to be less toxic or
you know than having well I'll tell you
I mean I've given up certain things like
I don't drink a Moscow Mule anymore like
I make a mean ass Moscow Mule I love
that drink so much I love the ginger
beer the lime the whole ritual but what
I really decided was it's just not worth
combining sugar and alcohol together you
know the you know once in a while you
can have sugar once in a while you'd
have alcohol putting the two together is
like me you might as well just kick
yourself in the nuts so I just don't
want to do that
so certainly mix drinks are things that
I think just don't have a place in civil
society if you care about your liver if
you don't care about your liver by all
means drink all the mixed drinks in the
world certain I don't experience this
personally I don't seem to have any
issue with red wine I don't get
hangovers I don't get headaches even if
I have a couple glasses of red wine but
I've certainly seen patients who see a
real difference in red wine consumption
and it really seems to sit poorly with
them similarly if I drink like my sort
of dark favorite super duper Belgian
beer I don't seem to get any bloating or
anything from it but I've seen people
who who can't really handle that stuff
either
now that would although it's not a mixed
drink I mean you're getting plenty of
maltose in that right so I mean you're
getting a nice little it's the fructose
that I'm most worried about it's the
fructose in the ethanol combined I never
want icy because they both go through
this similar metabolic pathway and when
they're delivered in liquid form but
when the fructose is in a liquid form
and the ethanol which of course is in a
liquid form now you've combined the
velocity problem the kinetic problem is
working against you wouldn't be mad
so sugar as a liquid versus sugar is a
solid behave differently and it also the
dose matters but if you take a bolus of
liquid sugar
it's gonna make it further down the GI
tract then the solid and certainly in
animals the evidence Luke Hanley
actually published this study in science
about four months ago you could
basically take a mouse model that is
primed to get colon cancer and if you
you had three groups so one group is
getting just a bolus of glucose the
other group is just getting a bolus of
fructose liquid and the other is getting
a bolus of sugar glucose and fructose
together you could make that animal
explode in colon cancer with the sugar
the glucose fructose and the too much of
a tangent to get into the Y but it
turned out that that effect is probably
not present with solid sugar which does
not mean solid sugar doesn't come with
its own problems but it it's the ability
of the the transit time to get there
quickly if you know and not get absorbed
because it's not being held up in the
upper part of the GI tract with fiber
and other solid things that you'd have
say if you were eating it in the form of
fruit or even just in you know like a
piece of cake for example so again I'm
not suggesting oh it's good to eat cake
but the single worst thing you can do is
drink your sugar so many questions that
I'm going to table for now on on this
list on these three lists I should say
is there anything that you think I would
find particularly thought provoking or
hilarious that you'd like to share my
next thing on this stupid list is the
what if game have we talked about the
what if game I don't think so so I don't
know when this started it would
definitely before I got married
right but I I just I thought it was
really funny to play this game of would
you still like me if and then I would
make up something really stupid and even
the game itself bugs my wife but I make
her do it I make her go through the
explanation of why it's yes or no so I
still remember the very first one I did
would you still like me if yes and so
the very first one I ever did this has
probably been dating for like a few
months
and she came over to my place and I made
my one of my favorite meals is like a
curry stir-fry which is a very
labor-intensive meal you're carving up a
million different vegetables and all
this other thing and so we're sitting
there we're eating this thing she's like
oh this is great
and I was like would you still like me
if I was the exact same guy it always
gets prefaced by that wood used to like
me if I was the exact same guy but
instead of using a knife to cut these I
was like this really flexible guy with
long toe nails and I used my toe nails
to cut them so I sat cross-legged on the
floor and I sliced and diced all the
vegetables using my toe nails but I was
everything else about me is the same and
she's like and I was like I want you to
like literally picture this I'm the same
guy everything about me is the same
except for this one little thing which
is I just like to use my toenails to cut
the vegetables instead of a knife and a
you know chopping block then you know
she's sort of humor me with that and I
just went over and over and over again
to this day I still play this game
constantly and I actually asked her
before I came over I was like do you
remember some of the ones that really
like annoyed you and I would ask these
and so she reminded me with you so one
of them we were in Italy this summer and
we walk into a department store and they
have this big bright red speedo with a
gold belt and I was like would you like
me if I was the exact same guy but I
only wore this as my shorts so like I
would still wear shoes and a shirt but
instead of wearing like the shorts that
I'm wearing now like I would only wear
this bright red speedo would the big
gold belt the European this this
American Hero yes yeah and she's like
yeah probably not and I'm like and then
of course whenever she says that I'm
always like how can you be so
superficial like how can that one thing
be such a deal-breaker another one that
she remembered was car dancing I was
like what if I was the exact same guy
but I was I would dance like crazy while
I was driving and then I would mock do
you remember in sixteen Candles when
Anthony Michael Hall is dancing around
Molly Ringwald at the dance yes I would
do that dance but I always did that
while driving and I was like what if I
was exactly
but I did that what if I wanted to watch
The Smurfs for two hours every single
day
I loved the Smurfs like the Smurfs the
TV show the relation yeah not movie yeah
that's right so like I loved hefty Smurf
and I was totally obsessed with him
hefty remember hefty Smurf was like
there really muscular I don't remember
hey yeah yeah and I just had like a long
list these no no I just always do it I
always play the what I loved playing the
what if game and I'm calm I'm actually
kind of amazed at the amount of times
she would just veto me based on the
stupid thing I said well I would imagine
at some point she was like how can i
he's not gonna let me out of this so
like how do I cut this short or make it
interesting for myself but if anybody
else is listening to this and you're
trying to just insert a little spice in
your life I can't suggest the what if
game highly enough it's really where
you'll find out like where the rubber
hits the road yeah how much would it
take how much would I have to pay you to
that's another good one yeah yeah yeah
that one that one devolves quickly in my
experience if if more than two guys are
involved generally speaking especially
if one of them's Kevin Rose awful
hashtag keV keV sorry but I remember one
time I just have to give Kevin some [ __ ]
since we know him so well I don't know
if I've ever talked about this publicly
but Kevin was sort of famous I don't
think he does this as much anymore
but he was famous among the friend group
I had in the Bay Area for betting people
to do things right I'll give you the
I'll give you whatever amount if you do
this and you would do this all the time
to try to get people in trouble or not
in a malevolent way mind you just to
like create mischief be like I'll give
you X if you do this and that we were
out at a steak house in San Francisco
and there
this bottle of Tabasco or something like
that
and we're like 80% done with the meal
and I had ordered surf and turf from
people that ordered various things and
Kevin goes if you drink that whole
bottle of hot sauce I'll give you $20
and I was like okay time out
Kevin you're not [ __ ] poor and you
are from me $20 to basically destroy my
genius drawing my GI tract maybe have to
like tap out for two days or I go to the
hospital
how [ __ ] cheap are you like that's
embarrassing you should be ashamed of
yourself and I had just finished the
lobster tails or no there's more to it
it was like a full lobster or half shell
or whatever and I was working on my
steak and I said you know what $20
that's [ __ ] I'll give you $10,000 if
you can eat this Lobster shop an entire
table and to his credit he actually took
a crack at it and he he like an inch and
a half of one of the antennae and was
like guy can't do this but you did give
it a shot
so so here's another question how many
times in the history of let's just limit
it to homo sapiens
do you think that game has been played
by females you know if we're talking
just because this is getting weighting
into dangerous territory but if we're
talking just knee-jerk response when it
gets to like dangerous levels of
stupidity I definitely put that on the
low side very few yeah I just I don't
know what it is about guys that make us
so dumb when it comes to this stuff yeah
I mean there's a just to maybe give
people a showcase but broadly for
context in high school for $2 I drank an
entire bottle one liter 750 ml of lemon
juice
oh you know that real lemon lemon juice
stuff ah 750 ml for two dollars I like
it in high school terrible oh I pretty
much perforated my system
make terrible but it was like oh wait
you're you're you're egging me on to do
this oh yeah I'll do that yeah there's a
there are many Instagram accounts that I
sort of rubberneck at watching and I
this probably came via one of my friends
who shall remain nameless but it's
pretty sure it's just called doing
things wrong and it's basically people
[ __ ] up like everything you can
imagine possible BMX bike riding Park or
whatever and the ratio like the
male-female ratio is is astonishing it's
astonishing and also completely
unsurprising at the same time it's just
like all guys you're like you see it
coming from a mile away you're like
terrible terrible terrible idea and then
boom pay off yep turns out that was a
bad idea it's just sort of funny to
think like it's possible our species
couldn't have got here like it's
possible like there's at least another
parallel universe that didn't quite make
it because the male reproductive end of
the bargain could not be lived up to do
to just constant stupidity I don't I
think it's a fine line right I mean I
don't I don't think we're that far away
from that already right it's just well
now it's different cuz evolution isn't
the thing that's like it's not gonna be
natural selection that kills us now
we'll just kill ourselves directly but
like natural selection could have
basically weeded us out just based on
male stupidity oh yeah I mean I'm I
don't have kids you know I'm astonished
that I haven't won the Darwin Award yet
right at this point alright let's do one
more excited or changed mind on that you
think might be a good closer well the
other one I had unexcited was was which
it really owe a lot of credit to you is
is this whole sort of podcasting thing
and and learning learning might even be
too strong a word practicing this art of
interviewing it is so you know this
whole thing started as sort of an
experiment a year and a half ago and I
just didn't I couldn't have imagined how
enjoyable it is I mean I think what
you're doing today is way more fun than
what I'm doing I don't actually like
being asked questions that much anymore
but I love
questions yeah and I find myself
listening to podcasts much more than I
ever did before and listening to now two
things one is what's the content you
know but also and perhaps as importantly
if not more importantly is how was this
interview extracting that how was this
interviewer what are they thinking what
would I have thought at that moment did
they think of though they went down a
path I wouldn't have thought of okay how
can what can I take away from that so
the good side of that is I think it
allows me to try to you know become
better at this craft the downside
honestly is I feel much more pressure
now I feel and not to the point where
it's taking away or detracting from the
experience but I I've had to now go back
and listen to some of my own podcasts
because that's one way you learn is you
you sort of feel like an listened to and
that's just as you probably know that's
a very painful thing to do like do you
ever listen to your own podcast oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely I think you
have to if you want to get better at it
yeah you have to I mean it's like
reviewing footage of a training session
or something it's it's a requirement I
think if you want to do post game
analysis and prove what you're doing but
it can be really painful it's super
tough so it is again yet another thing
like archery like racecar driving where
you know there's this opportunity to be
somewhat critical in this period of
trying to get better but it's also
opened me up to a new world I never
really paid attention to before which is
journalism like you know sort of TV
journalism or radio journalism where you
know you gotta be able to think on your
feet you've got to be able to multitask
and for me I don't know if you feel this
way but I think the hardest thing is to
somehow parallel process being engaged
in the discussion that you're having but
allowing a part of your brain to be
thinking about where you are on a path
and where you want to go and those are
that is that's like next-level ninja
mooves it is what's what surprised me
maybe the most about the podcast
interviewing game or the format of of
one-on-one
one hour plus interviews is that is how
coachable and improvable many of the
components skills are I've really been
astonished by that and one example of
that would be the ability to bookmark
even when not taking notes right now I
took notes throughout this conversation
in case I wanted to come back to
something but even in the case of not
taking notes the ability to bookmark
departure points where your interviewee
goes off in a different direction and
the capacity to then return to those
bookmarks as if you had flagged them
that that is an ability that lets throw
an arbitrary number on it like 10x to my
ability to do that in any conversation
visa V the podcast and it makes you
wonder like what are the cognitive like
what's the mechanism behind that and
like it does that transfer to anything
else like am i unbeknownst to me
developing other cognitive functions
that kind of correlate to that right and
certainly listening listening to your
own audio really showcases any tics that
you have or any pet phrases or any words
that you tend to start too many
sentences with I used to go sue sue sue
so and I listen to this audio it's
agonizing and then there was one
interview in particular I'd love to hear
I know that intros drove you completely
insane for a period of time Bill burr
okay so we can come back to that I don't
think people fully appreciate how
torturous that process can be but I
interviewed Edie Catmull who I think
he's still the president picks her but
at the time was president of Pixar and
he was coming out with a book that great
book actually think it's creativity Inc
and he was the first guest ever on the
podcast who I had never had a prior
conversation with or I never had a prior
I had never had a conversation with him
prior to the recording and there was a
mixup in communication and he thought
the podcast was a lot shorter than mine
time mm-hmm right he's a busy guy and he
wasn't angry
he wasn't hypercritical but it's it got
off to a tense start because I was like
how do i reconcile this
can we go longer and it was just an
unexpected variable to deal with and I
was I was very nervous going into it to
begin with and did the interview I was
quite happy with it all things
considered and then I'm looking at
feedback on Twitter and I see three
tweets in a row that ah that our mmm dot
dot dot
mmm dot dot dot and I see a few of these
and I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
and I go back and I listen to the audio
and every time he said anything I want
mmm-hmm
a [ __ ] hour an hour and a half
whatever was and I just could not
believe how [ __ ] oblivious I was to
the fact that I was doing that every 15
seconds and I can't think of 15 of us
right yeah and uh or at one point I
don't know what it was it was another
nervous tic and one of my interviews
notes going sound like a [ __ ]
chipmunk on my shoulder chewing acorns
for the whole interview oh for sure
I mean those things stress me out but
not nearly as much as the bigger picture
of missing the Exeter like if it if an
interview is a discussion where you're
driving down a road it's like missing a
side road yeah you know missing a
missing a side road and getting lost or
go and I don't know I mean I I think I
am better than I was at the outset but I
think this is definitely like the
steepest learning curve and there's so I
mean I have an aspiration for what it
can be and I do love listening to great
interviewers now in the podcast space
it's a bit misleading so if you listen
to somebody like Steve Dubner who I
think is fantastic that type of a
podcast is produced freakanomics yes
yeah and and so that's a little bit
different but you know III mean I love
listening to Katie Couric
I love listening to people do long-form
interviews and you know I've asked I've
actually asked Katie for some for some
advice which has been great and I any
chance I get to ask somebody who does
this for a living do you recall what you
asked her and what she responded with or
or anything that you've picked up from
good which is nothing what's the best
piece of advice I've been given so far
or any good advice well well I'll
definitely tell you at the outset the
hardest part I had was I and it's
embarrassing because you feel like such
an idiot when you're doing it and you
realize it as it happens is you're
talking over the person you know and I
just think like in your excitement you
sometimes just like okay but I have
another question now it's like I want to
forget these other I don't to forget all
these questions
so that's something where it's a lot
easier in person because body language
makes that easier to avoid I do most my
nerves in person so that that's a bit
easier I think in the end I've learned
it comes down to prep you know you you
really the better interviews are ones
where I feel like I'm more prepared and
the interviews that I come out of where
I think man like I can't believe I
didn't know all of these other things
that would have allowed me to take this
discussion in another direction there
are so many different styles of
interviewing right I remember early on I
was very lucky I don't know how this
happened to be introduced to one of the
head researchers if not the head
researcher for Inside the Actors Studio
and I asked him if you'd be willing to
look at transcripts of some of my
interviews to offer pointers or
observations and it was very very
valuable and the point that he made as a
preface to feedback was exactly what I
said and that is there are many
different ways to skin the cat and James
Lipton who is fantastic in his role as
the interviewer slash host of inside the
Actor's Studio
almost never changes the order of
questions once he has a stack of
questions on blue cards he will not
deviate he almost without exception
knows the answers to every question he's
going to ask and that's say one end of
the spectrum then you have a Larry King
and there are others of sort of Larry
King's school of interviewing who go in
I'm not going to say blind but
intentionally with beginner mind not
knowing much about the the interviewee
unless they've met them before so that
they can ask questions kind of from
first principles mm-hmm mimicking the
listeners experience and then you have a
lot in between you have a ton in between
and as you noted the produced shows like
this American life or Freakonomics are
spectacularly good but they're very
different from a minimally edited
long-form interview of say two hours or
where we are to almost two and a half
hours and the ability to
compartmentalize like you like you said
to parallel process is also something
that I could not do in the beginning and
I'm not saying I'm the epitome of skill
or ability with it now but it does seem
to be a faculty that you can cultivate
who are other interviewers you've paid a
lot of attention to I mean I certainly
when I was getting started I listened to
and still do listen to quite a bit of
rogan drogon Marc Maron very different
styles I'm both very skilled with very
different styles I think Steve Rinella
actually is a fantastic
interviewer he's is such a
subject-matter expert with a lot of what
he does and there are many many other
people who are just outstanding but is
there any way is there anyone who's who
I think part of the problem is I'm still
trying to figure out where I am on that
spectrum you know so so I think one of
the goals I have for next year is to
hone this craft even more and and
actually sort of figure out what my
voice is and then sort of start to
double down on the learning around that
now of course again you could argue that
being
would be the best outcome being able to
do one extreme or the other I don't go
into interviews with questions but I go
in with a lot of prep I have a team that
helps with that so so I go in with you
know four or five sometimes then I have
their podcast a week ago with 28 pages
of notes going in but none of them were
questions it was just content do you
refer to those pages in the midst of the
interview yeah so what I usually do is
I'll say to the person I'm an interview
and sometimes I'd actually if you don't
mind me interrupting and talking on top
of you for a second what does what do
the prep instructions look like when
your team helps you prep what are their
marching orders what do they do it's it
varies totally by the podcast for this
one for the 28 page one this was a
podcast which was very difficult because
I was interviewing two people so that's
I've only done that three times or maybe
even twice and it's much harder to
interview two people and like you these
are people I like the example you gave
I'd never spoken with them before so I
identified them as subject matter
experts the subject was THC CBD all
things related to cannabis so identified
them as exactly the two smartest people
I wanted to talk to in the room but had
never said I was all through email no
communication otherwise and I said to my
team look these are things I want to
understand that I don't know I believe
these are things the public wants to
know I need a dossier that is the best
available knowledge you have on all of
these topics and then I'm gonna
basically look where the gaps are and
I'm gonna sort of run the sled between
the gaps in the snow did you send five
to ten bullets per silo in terms of what
Peter wants to know what the public
might want to know I mean how much you
sending to your team as a starting point
um so in that case I think I think Jess
took the lead on that analysis no I
think actually just took the first cut
so she came back with kind of like ten
pages of stuff and then I was like okay
let me digest this for what did you
provide her first no like literally
nothing blank space Oh was blanks but
yeah total blank space and then she came
back and then I reject it and said okay
well
I also need to know more about this more
about this more about this this is good
here thank you this one is good but can
you give me a little bit more insight so
that's like one extreme end of the
spectrum and then other podcasts that I
mean I have podcast where I literally go
in with nothing except blank paper to
take notes on well we're speaking kind
of like what you and I are doing right
now for you where you you know there's
nothing you need to prep for this type
of an interview but and then there's
very technical ones actually I do have
28 pages to my right on egg boxing but
we didn't manage to folia unpack that
next time I mean it's just it's such a
nascent space you know the bottom line
is it's I'm a little embarrassed
sometimes when I listen to myself
interview you know I when you hear it
the second time you think how did you
how did you miss that thing that they
said like they said something so
important they were opening a door here
and you didn't even go in that door and
that's another I think part of what what
the people who were good at this can do
is they can release their own agenda and
sometimes go where the story is more
interesting and I've definitely seen
many examples of how I've missed that
opportunity I had a lot of trouble with
that also and a fixation on remembering
questions which is actually part of the
reason why I still often recommend to
novice podcasters that they pre record a
number of episodes via phone first
meaning via Skype and he can't call her
quarter or Zen caster because it it
allows the ability to look at notes so
that you're not as preoccupied what I've
found very helpful for myself is more of
a structural prep than a content prep in
the sense that I will decide as a
placeholder and it's not something that
I fixate on but to have say a post-it
note to my side which says first thirty
this type of stuff next thirty this type
of stuff next thirty this type of stuff
but no specific questions yeah and then
I will look at the recording time and
segue roughly at those two pivot points
the other thing that I found really
really helpful and this mirrors how I've
done a lot of my best writing which I
haven't
quite a while and I'm gonna be getting
back into writing that is knowing which
handful of questions I'm going to start
with and it might only get through two
and then where I want a book end it
questions I think could lead to a a
grand finale or a nice way to wrap up
and then in between it's just looking
for the side streets again a hard time
it's it's it's a fun craft I mean again
if this is sort of like archery sort of
like driving a racecar anybody can do it
it's hard to do really really well
yeah it's like I think it's bushnell's
law well this was in the gaming world in
context of Atari at the time but I want
to say that the quote is roughly a great
game is easy to learn hard to master
mm-hmm yeah that'll keep it moving for a
long time yeah absolutely so Peter tell
people where they can find you they want
to listen to the most meticulous
dissection of subjects like THC CBD MRI
longevity you've got all manner of
subjects I mean you also introduced me
to Ryan Flaherty the savant of speed
mm-hmm it comes to physical training you
cover a lot the podcast is the drive and
the drive and I exist on any sort of
whatever my web you know websites
Twitter Instagram is all Peter attea MD
Peter ta MD dot-com and that's only
because Peters here was taken I hate
having and I can't say it without
thinking about Meet the Parents dr. Bob
Bob MD if my wife still makes fun of me
for that Peter to UM D if if you had a
blog post or series of blog posts that
you would suggest people start with if
they want to explore your thinking in
the written medium where would you
suggest people start is there anywhere
you would suggest they start we have a
five
part series on science understanding
science called studying studies yes
that's so good yeah I think that that's
that's a helpful one if you consume news
about health you know you what you do
right it's not - yeah if you read if you
are exposed to media that contain any
health claims whatsoever
then chances are you're coming across
yeah so that's show increased risk of
colorectal cancer 47% right yeah so if
you want to get to the fine print so
studying studies which which Bob Kaplan
and I wrote in 2017 I believe I think
that's I think that's a great place to
start for folks great and I'll link to
that at Tim Ferriss mtv.com no I I don't
all shamelessly plug for a Sunday
newsletter which I think you like yeah
we if you you can sign up for what I
described is a non lame weekly email I
get your emails in there aren't that
many emails that I subscribe to because
I haven't enough in my inbox but yours
is one I get one of the few and I will
link to the newsletter your newsletter
and everything else that we've talked
about it Tim vlog a forward slash
podcast just search Atia atti a and I'll
pop right up anything else you'd like to
say closing comments limericks
I think anything else I don't think so I
think I could certainly offer about 20
more dumb things I do but we could save
it for follow up if you guys enjoyed the
format please let me know in the blog
comments that accompany of this podcast
or on Twitter at T Farris two hours two
S's just let me know if you liked or
hated this format or anything in between
the kind of five things with person acts
might do three things with five things
with whatever we get the idea kind of
excited about change mind about and then
stupid absurd things thinking about
doing more of these cuz it's a damn easy
plug-and-play format for one thing
and Peter we we have a we've dinner date
and we will get to that at some time in
the very very near future so I guess on
top of G be damned here comes the
calories and thanks for making the time
thank you
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell that out and just drop in with
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you enjoy
it
this episode is brought to you by Paulo
Tom I love peloton peloton is a
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings live studio classes right to your
home you don't have to worry about
fitting classes into your schedule
making it to the studio or dealing with
some commute to the gym I have a peloton
bike in my master bedroom at home and it
is one of the first things that I do in
the morning I wake up meditate for 20
minutes and then I knock out a short 20
minute ride usually high-intensity
interval training or hit then I take a
shower
and I'm in higher gear for the rest of
the day it's beautifully convenient and
has become something that I actually
look forward to and I was skeptical in
the beginning I didn't think I would dig
it and I really do oh you have a lot of
options for one if you like you can ride
it live with thousands of other Politan
riders from across the country on the
interactive leaderboard to keep you
motivated I tend to use a lot of the
classes on demand
four to six of them that I bookmarked
and use over and over again there are up
to fourteen new classes every day with
thousands of classes on demand and there
are a variety of workouts to choose from
45-minute class it's 20 minute burns hip
hop rock and roll low impact or high
intensity pick the class structure and
style that works for you
peloton has an amazing roster of
incredible instructors in New York City
they really do have great instructors of
every possible personality style and
that you can find one that you love no
matter what you're in the mood for
personally I use Matt Wilbur's a lot but
I use a bunch of them I'm promiscuous
and enjoy classes from a lot of their
instructors with real time metrics you
can track your performance over time and
continue to beat your personal best I
did not think the gamification would
work for me and they really hit the nail
on the head it does work at least for me
tremendously well to keep me pushing
consistently so discover this
cutting-edge indoor cycling bike that
brings us to to experience to your home
Pelton is offering listeners of this
podcast a limited time offer
go to one colleton comm that's spelled
pho and PL o t om calm enter the code
Tim podcast all onward at checkout and
get $100 off accessories with your
palette on bike purchase get a great
workout at home any time you want go to
one peloton calm and use the code ten
podcast to get started this episode is
brought to you by humans beat elites
the product is beat elite not meet elite
not beat baat but beat Vee T elite which
you might consider an endurance
superfood or what they would call a
nitric oxide activator really all I care
about is this product feedly was
introduced to me several years ago by a
multiple time world champion and has
since been recommended to me by multiple
world-class athletes and I use it free
workout for endurance
that could be cycling that could be
swimming it is very rarely running but
my subjective experience supports what
some of the research would seem to
indicate and that is that you can work
out say up to 15 to 18% longer if you're
looking at high-intensity interval
training hit for instance and at
recovery times so the let's call it the
refractory period for getting back to
peak power output for instance so I use
people they just use it this morning
before a 30 minutes somewhat intense
swim workout and I have found that
particularly for someone like myself who
has really terrible endurance
genetically speaking my precess are
horrible that it really does allow a 10
to 20 percent boost in shorter workout
performance especially although I do
know people who have used it for 20-mile
runs 30 mile runs much longer endurance
events and they've got all sorts of
different points about the mechanisms of
action and so on but suffice to say that
it is a lot easier to consume belief
than to eat the nitric oxide equivalent
have six whole beats for instance much
more rapidly assimilated and it tastes
great
it will also stain your pet polar bear
or your white cotton or your down
pillows so to put spill it on anything
but it does taste delicious I tend to
mix this into a shake that I have free
workout in the morning so there you have
it I've used beat elite for a number of
years now it is trusted by hundreds of
elite teams athletes and organizations
all over the world and it is also
informed sports certified which means
that it is certified to not contain any
banned substances so if you're a
competitive athlete that is one fewer
thing that you need to worry about so
take your performance to the next level
with beat elite try it out go to live
human calm slashed him to get 20% off
your first purchase the team at human
that's the company is making this offer
exclusive to you my dear listeners so
check it out go to live human calm slash
Tim super simple live human calm slash
Tim give it a shot